Die letzten 82 Folgen haben uns alle wahnsinnig gelangweilt und ich bin ja auch schon mal weggenickt. Ich möchte den Jungs da überhaupt keinen Vorwurf machen. Ich sage das seit langen Jahren, dass unser Podcast-Betrieb völlig aufgebauscht ist und aufgebauscht wird und das scheint kein Ende zu nehmen. Und die Spitzenpodcaster, von denen wir hoffen, dass sie top Leistungen bringen, die sind für mich völlig überlastet und aus diesem Grunde glaube ich auch, dass sie eben auch nicht ihre top Leistungen abrufen können. Die werden sich jetzt vielleicht mal wieder in den entsprechenden Folgen hochpushen. Das macht ja sein. Dann werden sich die Hörer anschließend wieder freuen können. Die haben jetzt keinen Urlaub, die haben keine vernünftige Vorbereitung und sind dann voll im Podcast wieder drin. Das kann man sehen, wo Podcastler da landen, wenn ich ihn gucke, ist der 31. Der hat gefühlt die Karriere eines 37-Jährigen hinter sich. Jede zweite Woche. Diese Leute können sich fast nie wieder regenerieren und erholen. Ich halte das für sehr, sehr gefährlich. Das Entscheidende ist, dass Leute Spaß an den Podcasts haben. Aber ich glaube, dass wir unser Produkt seit langen Jahren immer mehr verwässern. Weil es eben nicht geht, dass du 4 Stunden wieder auf hohem Niveau sein kannst und noch mal, noch mal, noch mal, wenn ich mich in den Podcasten versetzen würde, ich wäre froh, wenn ich nach Hause gehen könnte, wenn ich mal Urlaub machen dürfte. Ich hätte gar keinen Bock da zu sein, muss ich ehrlich sagen. Den Jungs wird so viel abverlangt und am Ende des Tages ist es auch ein Podcast, was Spaß machen soll und Spaß machen muss. Es ist zwar auch harte Arbeit, aber ich muss auch frei im Kopf sein, ich muss frisch sein, ich muss richtig Lust haben. Und die Jungs werden immer und immer und immer wieder ins Feuer geschickt. Ich glaube nicht, dass ihr euch hier eine Vorstellung davon machen könnt, was das bedeutet.
Ja, frisch ins Feuer eingetaucht. Ja, ich hoffe natürlich, dass ihr euch von einem letzten Einsatz schon habt gut regenerieren können. Auch Podcasts sitzen dann irgendwann mit der Entlümpfungshose auf dem Sofa.
Was ist denn eine Entlümpfungshose bitte?
Na ja, das sind so Hosen, die ziehen die halt an und die, ich weiß nicht ganz genau wie sich das anfühlt, aber die üben irgendwie so Druck aus auf alles und machen dich auch irgendwie, keine Ahnung, also da wird halt der Lymph wieder in Wallung gebracht, so damit die Spieler halt auch nach ein paar Tagen wieder wie die bekloppten Soos podcasten können.
Die geistige Entlümpfungshose, genau, so sieht es aus.
Sehr seriös fängt das hier schon wieder an. Ja, David hat wieder ganz tief in die Fußballkiste gegriffen, ich finde das schön, super. Und weiß da jemand von euch, wer das war?
Nein, also ich nicht.
Wahrscheinlich der, der gerade entlassen wurde.
Ne, noch nicht.
Noch nicht entlassen.
Noch nicht entlassen. Dann kann es nur von Union sein.
Ne.
Dann bin ich raus.
Ich weiß, dass ihr es nicht wisst. Ich kann euch natürlich jetzt trotzdem über ein Feuer zappeln lassen. Aber der Chet, der tolle Freak Show Chet Schleck, der hat schon richtig geraten. Das war Zettel Ewald. Zettel Ewald, Zettel Ewalds Rand über die Überlastung.
Aktuell oder?
Nicht ganz unaktuell. War jetzt nicht gestern, aber war auch nicht letzten Monat.
Also so dazwischen.
Ja, irgendwas dazwischen. Genau. Also ich kann jetzt kein Datum nennen. So oder so frisch in den Feuertopf gestiegen ist für euch die Freak Show und wir sind mal wieder live. Heute auch ohne Themen, haben wir gerade festgestellt.
Na ja, nicht ganz.
Also so ist es ja auch nicht. Aber es wird sportlich und von daher ist das jetzt schon mal nicht der schlechteste Einstieg. So, Roddy ist auf jeden Fall da.
Guten Abend.
Bist wieder da oder warst du letztes Mal nicht da?
Ja, ich war auch vorletztes Mal nicht da, glaube ich.
Stimmt, du bist schon eine Weile weg gewesen. Warum eigentlich?
Na, letztes Mal lag ich mit einer Darmgrippe im Bett, die Gott sei Dank ohne größere Zwischenfälle ablief.
Vorletztes Mal warst du dabei, sehe ich gerade.
Die mir es trotzdem nicht ermöglicht hat, hierher zu kommen, sagen wir mal so.
So, auch wieder da ist Letty. Warst letztes Mal nicht dabei?
Ich hab letztes Mal entschuldigt gefehlt.
Aber vorletztes Mal. Du kommst jetzt sozusagen nur noch mit Roddy.
Ja, genau.
Und Dennis, man hört ihn vielleicht schon, wir hören ihn.
Test, Test, 1, 2, 3.
Vaders, so wie Trump, der hat auch die ganze Zeit rumgewedert.
Aber letztens hier, da war ich das gar nicht, da war...
Das war Letty dann.
Ja, also Letty wedert auch.
Ich werde auch.
Ja, und Ikke und Hucke lässt sich, glaube ich, entschuldigen. Sollte er nicht noch durch irgendein Wink des Schicksals hier ins Studio gespült werden. Und Clemens hat einfach keine Zeit. Er meint, er hätte immer nur die Mittwoche dazwischen Zeit. Das ist aber keine Absicht von uns, sondern das...
Das ist Absicht von ihm.
Das wissen wir nicht. Da kann ich mich jetzt nicht so äußern. Ja, genau. Und am Mischpult der Tim. Mich stellt ja mal keiner vor. Mach ich das vielleicht mal selber. Mir wird ja eh vorgeworfen, ich wäre sehr ichbezogen. Also von mir. Und weil auch das übernehme ich dann doch lieber selbst.
Stell dich mal besser vor, sonst weiß keiner, wer da spricht.
Genau. Ja, und das ist euer Team für eine Woche, in der es immer noch keine neuen MacBooks gibt.
Schande.
Wollen wir noch? Ich weiß auch nicht. Also gut, die Gerüchteküche meinte, meinte die Gerüchteküche eigentlich irgendwas? Oktober, ne?
Irgendjemand hat ja dem Timme irgendwie eine Mail geschickt, dann hat gesagt, ey jo, wie sieht's denn aus? Und der hat geantwortet, stay tuned. Ich dachte, es kommt im Oktober.
Aber wir wissen halt noch nicht, wat? Wir wissen halt nicht, ob sie...
Diese komische Touch-Leiste.
Ob sie diese komische Touch-Leiste machen, wir wissen nicht, ob sie die Escape-Taste beerdigen, wo ich wirklich erzürnt wäre.
Vielleicht schmeißen sie auch die Klinke raus. Vielleicht braucht es schon eine Klinke am Rechner.
Das ist eine gute Frage, aber wenn sie die Klinke rausreißen, würde ich mich halt fragen, was statt dessen? Machen wir noch nicht wirklich einen Lightning-Port an einen Mac ran.
Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Nee, wenn die da einen Adapter machen, das Ding hat ja irgendwie USB 3, Trailer, wie auch immer das gerade heißt, da blickt ja keiner mehr durch irgendwie, dann muss man sich da halt einen Adapter holen, gibt es ja ohne Ende. Deswegen ist einfach da, wenn die den weglassen, ist einfach nichts dabei. Ich glaube, einen Adapter legen die ja auch nicht dabei.
Man hat so den Eindruck, die tun schon nichts anderes mehr. Max gibt es auf jeden Fall keine.
The Universal Adapter, von allem auf alles?
In Wirklichkeit ist Campus 2 hier der große UFO. Es ist ja nur Adapter Development. Der Rest bleibt ja da in Pubertier.
Du meinst, das Raumschiff ist nur für die Adapter da? Und für die Energiegewinnung?
Die das nämlich kostet, immer diese ganze Austauscherei an Steckern.
Wo wir gerade bei Apple sind...
So ein Zufall.
Da es ja sozusagen nicht Substantielles zu erzählen gibt. Dachte ich mir, reden wir mal über irgendwas unsubstanzielles. Habt ihr dieses Gerücht gehört, dass sie McLaren kaufen wollen, sollen werden?
Gehört habe ich das Gerücht.
Ja, habe ich auch. Da hat aber einer noch ein bisschen was genaueres zu geschrieben. Und zwar geht es gar nicht um das McLaren selbst, sondern die... Hättest du ja was gesagt, dass wir hier über sowas reden.
Ich habe den Link im Slack. Wenn du den Slack nicht liest, dann kann ich dafür nichts. Ich bin auch der Einzige, der da Links reinpostet.
Im Slack? Solltest du mal nachdenken.
Dann denke ich die ganze Zeit nach. Ich denke über fast jedes andere. Ich liege schweißgebadet jeden Abend in meinem Bettchen.
Hast du denn auch genau die Geschichte um diese Subfirma, die es da geht? Dann kannst du das ja erzählen, wenn du das noch genau weißt.
Also ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, worauf du anspielst, um ehrlich zu sein. Ich habe nur gerade was anderes noch gehört. Ob das sich darauf bezieht, weiß ich nicht. Geht es dabei um Research and Development?
Ja, ich glaube, das war es. Dass wir da so eine Bude haben, die auch jetzt nicht nur speziell für Autos, sondern so grundsätzlich auch viel Logistik und Zeug übernimmt und das alles so optimiert. Ich weiß es nicht mehr, das ist jetzt der Artikel, aber den gibt es nicht mehr bei Max Hörfer. Der ist schon weg, das war schon wieder zwei, drei Tage her.
Na, was ich gehört habe ist, also zunächst einmal, ich habe keine Ahnung, ob an diesen Gerüchten überhaupt irgendwas dran ist und selbst wenn das irgendwann mal erwogen wurde, ob das tatsächlich passiert oder nicht, aber ich finde irgendwie diesen Gedanken über dieses, wenn man so eine fette Bude ist wie Apple, wo man denkt ernsthaft darüber nach in Transportation einzusteigen, was sie ja vermutlich tun nach der Dichte, was baut man, also was konkret baut man? Na klar, kannst du ja sagen, ich bau ein Auto, aber was für ein Auto?
Eins für die Räder.
Wie benutzt man.
Das? Kannst du dir ein bisschen anders sein? Guck da so ein Einrad bei raus oder so. Keine Ahnung. Was ich nur bei McLaren gehört habe, ist, dass die Firma McLaren, die ja nun einerseits Sportwagen baut und andererseits Formel 1, Formel 1 Team ja noch an der Backe hat, dass die ein relativ hochentwickeltes Simulationssystem haben für ihre Karren. Das heißt, bevor die jetzt irgendeinen neuen Formel 1 Wagen oder vielleicht auch überhaupt irgendwie ein beliebiges Auto bauen, können sie quasi alle Parameter, die sie für dieses Auto planen, in diesen Simulator reintun. Und dann können halt die Fahrer quasi in diesem Simulator das Fahren, obwohl das Auto noch gar nicht existiert. Also die bauen da einfach in Software quasi in Realtime das gesamte Fahrverhalten dieses Autos nach, so wie sie sich das eben denken. Und dann können halt da Fahrer reingehen und sich das Ganze sozusagen durchtesten. Und das machen sie im Übrigen nicht nur für ihre eigenen Autos, sondern das machen sie auch für andere als Dienstleistung. Das heißt bei McLaren kannst du irgendwie hingehen und sagen, guten Tag, ich hätte hier gerne mal ein Dollar Auto, was ich gerne mal testen würde. Und dann lädst du da quasi vom USB-Stick dein Auto in diese Büchse rein und kannst das halt testen.
Also ich hab den Artikel jetzt hier gefunden, wo soll ich den mal hinschmeißen?
Den Slack.
Wo sind wir da?
Da.
Weißt du doch.
Hier. Ich hab das jetzt mal ohne die Klammern gemacht. Kommt ja da gleich. Also was hier in dem Artikel steht, wenn ich das jetzt noch mal kurz aus der Änderung vorhole, ist, dass McLaren was hat, wo sie halt auch lauter Sensordaten von ihren Prototypen und so, also auch bei was die bei der Formel 1 haben, sie haben ja tausende von Sensoren, wenn da so ein Fahrer fährt. Und die kann man ja erst mal einsammeln, das kriegt ihr ja dahin. Aber was die halt entwickelt haben, ist auch, dass sie die Sensoren mehr oder weniger in realtime und in sofort irgendwie aufbereiten und damit sofort und instant reagieren können. Und das ist wohl der Knackpunkt. Und das heißt McLaren Applied Technologies. Darum soll es wohl gehen. Ich mein zumindest dieser Artikel. Ich hab gar keinen Slack. Ich hab den ins Workiflowi geschmissen. Dieser Slack, da muss ich da erstmal warten, bis dieser neue Client irgendwie da ist und so. Ja, ja, ich starte ja schon.
Oh man, erst mal noch einen. Was ist das eigentlich hier?
Ja, wir müssen das mal kurz erwähnen, sonst vergessen wir das nämlich wieder, wie sonst auch immer.
So, jetzt hab ich's.
Wir haben Geschenke bekommen.
Ja, wir haben nämlich schon, ihr habt uns Glück, das war letztes Mal schon da. Ich hab dann bloß vergessen, das auf den Tisch zu legen. Absenderverein zur Förderung von Freak.EV. Aktionsfront Podcast. Club Marte 1.91.481 München-Steinhach. Und wir bedanken uns, da sind Süßigkeiten drin. Und obwohl ja alle schon so alt sind, kann sich keiner an Nappos erinnern.
Ich schon.
Die gab's auch früher immer im Kiosk.
Ich hab das noch nie gegessen.
Ich auch nicht, die sind mir zu hart.
Ja, jetzt auch nicht. Jetzt hältst du dich an die Schokowaffeln.
Ja, ich hab ja einen Nappo vorhin gegessen und hätt's fast teuer mit einem Zahnarztbesuch bezahlt. Aber ich glaub, ich bin jetzt drüber weg.
So, Letty, wenn Apple für dich ein Auto bauen sollen würde...
Was hieß denn das jetzt?
Und danke für das Schokobier.
Da ist jetzt noch so eine gefakte Bierflasche als Schokoladen...
Eine Schokoladen-Hohlfigur in Form einer Bierflasche.
Also was man normalerweise als Osterhase oder Weihnachtsmann gibt, das gibt's jetzt für die Zeiten zwischendurch auch als Bier.
Wenn Apple für mich ein Auto bauen müsste, bitte ohne Adapter.
Okay, naja gut, ohne Adapter wird's nicht gehen.
Bitte kein Touchscreen statt Lenkrad. Achso, ich fahr ja da nicht mehr, dann will ich's nicht.
Weiß ich nicht. Also ich meine, würdest du denn...
Du wirst müssen, weil geht nicht mehr anders.
Wieso? Ich kann auch aufs Fahrrad umsteigen. Dann sind wir da raus.
Ja, aber würdest du denn... Würdest du denn... Also was würdest du denn... Also würdest du überhaupt irgendwas haben wollen?
Ich wollte gerade fragen, was soll ich denn bitte für ein Problem haben, was sie lösen sollen mit einem Auto?
Na, was sind denn deine Transportoptionen, abgesehen vom Fahrrad?
Auto in der Stadt gar nicht, ist null Option. Gerade wenn man irgendwie raus in den Speckgürtel pendelt, ist man ja mit dem Auto eher stundenlang unterwegs. Also wäre für mich keine Option. Und das Einzige, wofür ich ein Auto brauche, ist um drin zu schlafen, wenn ich unterwegs bin. Also...
Tesla Model S Camper Mode. Na ja, Leute haben herausgefunden, wie man das Auto so einstellt. Also du kannst irgendwie die Rückband umklappen, und dann hast du genug Platz, dass du da irgendwie so kuschelig, aber zu zweit drin schlafen kannst. Dann haben die Leute herausgefunden, wie du das Auto so einstellst, dass es sich nicht ausschaltet, sondern die ganze Nacht über halt die Klimaanlage, die Temperatur hält und Frischluftzufuhr macht und so weiter. Dann hast du das Glasdach über dir, also es soll wohl sehr schön sein.
Hat das Ding eine Kofferraumklappe? Ich meine, da braucht man das mit der Lüftung auch nicht. Der macht mir die Kofferraumklappe eh auf.
Kofferraumklappe? Der Kofferraum ist doch nicht mit dem Innenraum verbunden. Doch.
Was? In welchem Auto denn bitte?
Nicht?
Klar, deswegen klappst du ja die Sitze um und dann hast du halt die vollen zwei Meter.
Ach so, und dann so die Füße in den Kofferraum rein oder was?
Na, oder Kopf. Ist ja egal.
Naja, die Klappe ist groß genug, dass du da halt einfach hinten einsteigst dann.
Also, kleine Klappe und viel dahinter.
Nee, ich glaub große Klappe.
Große Klappe und viel dahinter.
Ja, die kleine Klappe ist vorne.
Also ich hab, es gibt eine Fair Chance, dass wir hier demnächst mal so ein kleines Tesla-Spezial machen können. Nicht, dass wir uns sonst schon nicht darüber unterhalten würden, aber das Thema kommt sicherlich noch mal auf. Na gut, ich seh schon das Apple-Thema, das zieht bei euch nicht so richtig, ne?
Na doch, aber ihr habt ja nicht mehr weiter geredet, als Macleod an Zeugster.
Tja, kaum noch Fakten dazu.
Das wäre in der Tat interessant.
Man muss sich halt ja erstmal fragen, was würde man denn überhaupt haben wollen? Das Problem ist ja, wieder mal, da gibt's doch diesen schönen Ausspruch, stimmt ja eigentlich, den Mr. Ford, glaube ich, mal gesagt haben soll, bezüglich...
Man kann jede Farbe haben, Hauptsache schwarz?
Nein, nein.
Dass man Blixer bagelt.
Nein, er meinte, wenn ich meine Kunden gefragt hätte, was sie haben wollen würden, dann hätten sie alle gesagt, schnellere Pferde.
Und es stimmt, es wird kolportiert, aber ich weiß auch nicht, ob es echt ist.
Weiß ich auch nicht, aber es ist irgendwie versinnbildlich schön, diese Denke, die man irgendwie haben muss, wenn man jetzt quasi erfolgreich ein Produkt an Markt kriegen will, beziehungsweise wenn man im besten Fall natürlich auch maximal disruptiv auftreten möchte. Und nach dieser fortgesetzten Peinlichkeit, die die deutsche Automobilindustrie so an den Tag legt...
Fortgesetzte Peinlichkeit?
Na ja, ist doch so. Ich meine, BMW will ich da jetzt vielleicht mal rausnehmen, abgesehen davon, dass ich die Innenraumdesign schon seit Jahrzehnten als fortgesetzte Peinlichkeit empfinde. Das ist wirklich schlimm.
Schau dir doch einfach mal aus, wie bei den Elektroautos aussehen. Zum Weglaufen.
Ich habe ihn noch nicht gesehen, aber die i3?
Was soll ich denn da bitte ansprechen? Doch, es hat harte Kanten irgendwo. Also hier diese scharfen Kanten.
Also Johnny Ive muss man zumindest zugute halten, er ist Britter und hat Geschmack.
Also da haben wir doch neulich über die Autos gesprochen, die er so fährt und da hatte ich nicht das Gefühl, dass er Geschmack hat.
Ja, da war dieses eine Ding, von dem gesagt wurde...
Dieser rollende Panzer da. Der knauschte rollende Panzer. Ich hab da übrigens, da hat jemand gefragt, was denn mit meiner Model 3 Reservierung geworden wäre. Ich hab da neulich Post gekriegt, so ein Ding zum Aufklappen, wo irgendwie nur so ein Zettel drin war, Thank you for ordering a Model 3 Elon. Moment, ich hab noch ein Foto. Und dann war da so ne Zeichnung dabei. Also so ein Reprint von so ner Design-Zeichnung. Das ist ganz schick, hängt jetzt bei mir an der Wand, aber irgendwie so richtig Informationen sind da nicht drin. So, komm, uploaden. Na immerhin, da kriegst du ne Karte. Genau, das ganze Ding war so ungefähr DIN A4 ein bisschen größer. So ein Aufklappding sah so aus wie so ne Edelbewerbung. Mit so nem, naja, da hat der Designer halt das Auto gezeichnet. Das ist so, keine Ahnung, das ist vielleicht der Versuch, die Leute bei Laune zu halten.
Ja natürlich, ich meine bei denen Wartezeiten müssen sie auf jeden Fall ne ganze Menge Leute bei Laune halten. Ich find das immer wieder erstaunlich, wie zum Beispiel Volkswagen das irgendwie nicht schafft, Leute bei Laune zu halten. Ich bin ja immer noch kein Freund von den Gedanken.
Versuch des Volkswagen denn überhaupt?
Ja nicht ernsthaft. Also ich meine mittlerweile reden sie zumindest davon, aber sie sind ja nun gefühlt 5 bis 10 Jahre hinterher. Abgesehen davon, dass sie sich glaube ich ihren Brand in den USA einfach mal so dermaßen in den Teich versenkt haben. Da werden sie lange brauchen, bis sie da in irgendeiner Form wieder glaubwürdig werden. Und Diesel-Technologie ist in den USA jetzt ohnehin dood.
Aber das war in Ameland sowieso nie so angesagt, ne?
Nicht so wirklich.
Diesel-Technologie für Autos.
Nee, aber das war ja das Absurde, dass die Europäer in den letzten Jahren da ein Marketing-Boah hingelegt haben. Und halt immer wieder so mit deutsche Autos, Umweltschutz, nehmt Diesel, ist total... Das war ihr Selling-Point. In Deutschland glaubt das doch keiner. Hier fahren die Leute einfach Diesel, weil es billiger ist, weil LKW-Sprit halt einfach günstig gehalten wird. Und wenn du halt Diesel hast, musst du halt... Deutlich weniger Steuer drauf. So, das ist... Ich meine jetzt... Kann man mir jetzt nicht erzählen, dass das jetzt in Deutschland irgendwie eine große Diskussion war, dass jetzt Diesel so sehr viel umweltfreundlicher sind. Also meiner Wahrnehmung ist eigentlich Benzin und Diesel mehr oder weniger gleich wahrgenommen worden. Und es war ein reiner Kostenaspekt.
Also rein gefühlsmäßig wird, glaube ich, Diesel als Umwelt schädlicher wahrgenommen als...
Ja, also wenn überhaupt mit Feinstaubdiskussionen und so weiter war es tendenziell sogar noch schlechter. Aber in den USA haben es alle, also auch BMW und so weiter, Mercedes verkaufte halt einfach Dieselwagen. Beziehungsweise jetzt werden sie es wahrscheinlich nicht mehr tun, weil einfach Diesel als Konzept durch ist.
Also ich weiß nicht, wo Apple da punkten soll auf dem Automobilmarkt. Man sollte eher mal so überlegen, für was wird das Auto eigentlich hauptsächlich noch genutzt in Großstädten? Naja, wenn ich mir hier so Prenzlauer Berg anschaue, wo irgendwie jeder zwei Autos gefüllt hat, aber nur bis zu seiner Arbeit.
Das gefühlt täuscht, glaube ich.
Weil bei den Häusern, also du hast so ein Haus, sind, wenn es gut läuft, acht Parkplätze, aber 30 Mietparteien. Das heißt, wenn jeder Dritte ein Auto hat, dann sind es zu wenig Parkplätze.
Ja, aber ich meine, für was wird in Zukunft das Auto genutzt werden? Ich glaube, in der Innenstadt halt nicht. Also, wer nutzt denn das Auto? Sein eigenes Auto, wohlgemerkt.
Wer sagt denn, dass er ein Auto baut, was man kaufen kann?
Das ist ein Aspekt. Also, ich meine, erstmal gibt es natürlich Bevölkerungsgruppen, die haben einfach einen Autobedarf. Punkt.
Dann gibt es Landstriche, die haben einen Autobedarf. Amerika zum Beispiel.
Also, in der City und gerade in Berlin mit so einem verhältnismäßig gut ausgebauten ÖPNV, ist das eine ganz andere Sache. Wenn du irgendwie in der Pampa wohnst, auf einem Dorf, dann diskutierst du nicht über Auto haben oder nicht haben, dann entscheidet einfach Auto haben oder die Verfügbarkeit zumindest über ein Auto.
Ob du verhungerst oder nicht.
Ja, ob du verhungerst oder nicht, oder ob du in irgendeiner Form noch im gesellschaftlichen Leben teilhaber hast oder nicht. Also Autos sind jetzt nicht komplett raus. Es gibt da also Zielgruppen ohne Ende. Also abgesehen jetzt von dem ganzen Businessbereich, halt eben Pendler und einfach so Hausgebrauch, Carren. City ist halt noch mal ein anderes Ding, weil hier kannst du eben auch ganz andere Transportsysteme machen.
Und da haben wir ja auch schon oft darüber gesprochen, mit Carsharing etc.
Und das ist halt auch die Frage, wo steigen sie da ein? Ich meine, am Ende ist es ein amerikanisches Unternehmen und die sehen halt vor allem, dass das Problem bei den Amis einfach diese ganzen Vorstädte sind. Die haben halt einfach da überhaupt die Städte. Die Städte basieren auf der Idee, dass jeder ein Auto hat. Nimm die Autos da weg und nichts funktioniert mehr. Ich meine, du hast ja keinen Supermarkt in Lauf, überhaupt keine Infrastruktur. Da wird gewohnt, da wird gekauft, da wird Kino geguckt und damit, keine Ahnung, Sport getrieben. Und wenn du halt nicht so eine Scheiß-Kara hast, mit der du da hin und her gurgeln kannst, dann bist du halt durch. Deswegen haben sie ja dann auch irgendwie fünfspurige Autobahnen und Parkhäuser bis in den Himmel und was weiß ich nicht alles. Von daher ist das jetzt so in der Berlinersperspektive natürlich etwas schwieriger.
Ja, deswegen fällt es mir halt auch superschwer, überhaupt einen Use-Case zu finden für Apple, womit sie mich begeistern können. Weil mein Use-Case für Auto ist halt echt dran Pennen. Und rauskommen aus Berlin, um was anderes zu tun.
Dann bist du wahrscheinlich nicht diejenige, die in dieser Diskussion viel beitragen kann. Es sei denn, du bist in der Lage, dich von deiner eigenen Perspektive zu lösen? Auf eine andere Ebene zu stellen.
Vielleicht können sie ja ein schönes Innendesign machen für so einen VW Camper.
VW Camper, genau.
Naja, eine Weile lang wurde ja gerumort, dass sie eher so eine Art Van planen. Ich weiß nicht, was aus den Rumors geworden ist. Ob sich das nur jemand ausgedacht hat, der gehört hat, dass Steve Jobs mal einen VW Bus verkauft hat, um seine Firma zu gründen. Ich weiß es nicht. Aber, äh, also, keine Ahnung.
Das weiß halt keiner.
Das weiß keiner, ja. Aber wenn du dir halt anguckst, wie sehr traditionelle Autofirmen eigentlich nur noch Motor-Design machen. Und Elektromotoren sind keine schwierigen Dinge. Da musst du nicht zehn Jahre lang dran rumoptimieren und dann auch noch ein Bescheisssystem einbauen, damit du das Teil überhaupt zum Laufen kriegst. Sondern das sind halt ein paar Spulen und ein paar Magnete und fertig und dann fährt das Ding.
Naja, Fahrwerk muss schon auch ordentlich sein.
Ja, aber das Fahrwerk-Thema ist an sich ein gelöstes Problem.
Motor auch eigentlich.
Motor auch, Batterie ist halt kein gelöstes Problem.
Für ein E-Motor, ja.
Ja, also weil du brauchst halt Kapazität, du brauchst Leistungsfähigkeit und die Dinger brennen halt dann im Zweifelsfall ganz gut. Deswegen gibt es da schon Herausforderungen. Aber ich denke, wenn man halt in diesen Markt geht und man will maximal diskruptiv sein, muss man halt über ein System nachdenken. Ich finde übrigens den Vorschlag aus dem Chat gerade ganz schön. Let die Vivesse mit drin pennen und gleichzeitig automatisch rumgefahren werden.
Das ist irgendwie ganz nett.
Nachts einsteigen, morgens am Strand aufstehen. Über den Strand verbringen, abends einsteigen, morgens wieder nach Hause. Also am nächsten Tag wieder zu Hause sein.
Ja, das ist definitiv für einige interessant, aber...
Soffen nach Hause gefahren werden.
Dafür gibt's doch den Tim. Nee, mach mich den Tim nicht arbeitslos. Ich glaub, ich fahr einfach zu gern selber Auto, als dass ich das abgebe.
Ich hab's von Leuten gehört, die mit dem Autopilot-System Bekanntschaft gemacht haben.
Was mir aufgefallen ist, ich bin letztens in der Schweiz gewesen und von der Schweiz, weil schlechtes Wetter, nach Italien gefahren. Da fährst du durch diese furchtbaren Tunnel, wie der Gotthard-Tunnel, die extrem monoton sind. Ich hatte nach Kilometer 2 das Gefühl, verdammt bitte nicht einschlafen dabei. Weil es halt so müde macht. Und für so eine Situation stelle ich mir diesen Autopiloten und selbstfahrend echt super vor. Also wenn sie das relativ flott mal auf die Reihe bekommen, einzubauen, weil ich... Das ist... da fehlt mir der visuelle Eindruck. Also ich hatte jemanden zum Besparsen neben mir, aber das hat nicht gereicht. Also ich brauch da was für die Augen, wenn du wirklich so stark, die ganze Zeit auf die weiße Wand guckst. Und den wir einfach auf den Schoß setzen. Jetzt hab ich das Prinzip verstanden. Ach Mensch. Gut, werd ich das nächste Mal tun.
Wir kommen da jetzt nicht weiter.
Aber ehrlich gesagt, so selbstfahrende Autos finde ich total charmant. Also wenn die Technologie so weitergeht, dann hab ich in spätestens fünf Jahren mehr Vertrauen zu dem Auto, den Fahrkünsten des Autos als in meinen eigenen. Also das ist insofern, hab ich da glaub ich nicht so ein Problem mit.
Naja, Elon, dein Freund Elon.
Achso ja, hat er zumindest behauptet.
Hat er behauptet?
Er hat nur mit Elon unterschreiben lassen.
Und der will jetzt mit dir zum Mars fliegen, hat er gesagt.
Ich glaube, zum Mars fliegen ist dann doch auch eher so für die...
Muss er ja dann, wenn Apple ihm sein Autogeschäft kaputt gemacht hat.
Ja, das warten wir mal ab. Aber solange Elon nicht elektrisch zum Mars fliegt.
Also Tesla wird sicherlich nicht die erste Firma sein, die Apple aus dem Markt fegt. Sondern eher die letzte.
Ja, das glaube ich allerdings auch.
Also ich glaube Volkswagen ist als erstes dran.
Die wollen zum Mars fliegen. Ich habe nur dieses 3-Minuten-Intro-Video gesehen und dachte mir, holy shit, wann wollt ihr das machen? Und jetzt habe ich die Präsentation runtergeladen. Und es wird immer absurder. Also diese Rakete, die sie da bauen wollen, ist...
Fangen wir mal ganz kurz an, was überhaupt passiert ist.
SpaceX, die andere Firma von Elon, hat eine Präsentation darüber gehalten, wie sie sich das vorstellen, dann tatsächlich Leute zum Mars zu kutschieren. Und zwar so fast Shuttle-mäßig. Ich habe die ganze Präsentation nicht gesehen. Ich habe nur dieses Kurzding gesehen, wo sie da dieses gerenderte Video haben, was ein bisschen cheesy ist. Und die wollen irgendwie eine Rakete bauen, die 11 Meter höher ist als die Saturn V. Was die bisher größte Rakete ist. Selbst die Russen mit ihrer N-1 haben es nicht ganz so groß geschafft. Obwohl die N-1 irgendwie fast 60% mehr Payload hatte. Allerdings ist sie nur fünfmal geflogen und kein einziges Mal erfolgreich. Damit wollten die ja irgendwie ihre Manninnen auf den Mond bringen. Ja, also die Zahlen sind schon irgendwie beeindruckend. Aber das ist halt auch genau das Ding. Was war das, 42 Motoren in der Booster-Stufe unten drin? Es ist völlig absurd alles.
Warum?
Ja, weil es momentan keine Rakete gibt, die es mit der Saturn V aufnehmen kann, würde ich jetzt einfach mal behaupten. Ich weiß nicht, wie es mit der Falcon Heavy ist, aber die gibt es ja noch nicht. Die ist ja noch nicht geflogen.
Das ist auch kleiner, glaube ich.
Die Saturn V ist bisher das fetteste, was es gab und es bisher nicht erreicht.
Genau, und die Listen hier in dem Vergleich so ein paar Sachen auf. Und die Ratio bewegt sich bei vielen Werten so bei 3,5. Also 3,5 mal so viel Lift-Off-Maß, 3,6 mal so viel Thrust-Schub. Lift-Off-Thrust, ja, dann 4 mal höhere Expendable Low Earth Orbit Payload. Die wollen was? 550 Tonnen Payload in ein Low Earth Orbit bringen. Das sind einfach absurde Werte. Es erinnert mich so ein bisschen an Cargolifter. Muss ich mal ehrlich sagen. Das ist so jenseits dessen, was die Ingenieurskunst momentan irgendwie bewerten kann. Also...
Also bauen kann man das bestimmt.
Ja, aber zu welchem Geld?
Ja, das ist die Frage. Also ich meine, will er da Touristen jetzt hinschicken?
Quasi. Also eine Mars-Kolonie. Irgendwie 20 Leute pro Flug oder so. Das ist völlig absurd. Und ich hab da was gelesen, ist ja nicht total geil. Da meinte jemand, ja, Elon würde immer so eine Politik der exponentiellen Erwartungen schüren. Also nach der Art, wir bauen jetzt einen Tesla Roadster, um zu beweisen, dass Elektroautos geht und dann versprechen wir viel mehr. Und dann bauen wir ein Model S und dann versprechen wir nochmal viel mehr. Wir machen das jetzt alles in billig und das gleiche aber. Und jetzt kommt SpaceX mit diesem Ding um die Ecke und du denkst dir so, no way. Wie wollen die das finanzieren?
Also keine Ahnung, wie sie das finanzieren wollen. Übrigens hat er ja gesagt, dass er unter Umständen dieses Raumschiff Heart of Gold nennen möchte.
Super, aber warum nicht?
Es sieht ja auch tatsächlich so ähnlich aus. Also es sieht so ähnlich aus wie, also Heart of Gold ist ja das Raumschiff aus per anhaltet durch die Galaxie. Und da heißt es geschrieben, dass es weiß wäre, also wie seien es hier, ziemlich groß und tonschuhförmig. Und das ist jetzt mal nicht so ganz von der Hand zu weisen, dass das Ding so ein bisschen tonschuhförmig ist. Also vielleicht jetzt nicht wirklich so total genauso, aber...
Ich weiß ja nicht, was du für Tonschuhe trägst.
Du weißt nicht, was die Kids heutzutage für Tonschuhe tragen. Und wenn es dann so weit ist, dann tragen die auch Tonschuhe, die aussehen wie Raumschiffe und dann beißt sich das sozusagen schon wieder selber in den Schwanz.
Naja, ich weiß nicht. Als ich mir die Folien angeguckt hab, hab ich gerade eben von rechts neben mir die Frage gehört, was denn das sei, ob ich mir da Dildos angucken würde.
Sorry, das sieht nicht aus wie ein Tonschuhe.
Das sieht nicht aus wie ein Tonschuhe. Das Teil sieht ganz schön aus wie ein Dildo.
Der Mars-Dildo.
Der Mars-Dildo. Also so eine Saturn V stelle ich mir schmerzhaft vor. Aber so diese Mars-Rakete, das ginge eventuell. Also nicht, dass ich mich auskennen würde.
Na, Vibrato mit Unwahrscheinlichkeits-Drive.
Also, ja.
Also man muss schon sagen, da steckt natürlich jetzt, wenn ich eine ganze Menge, wie nennt man es, man könnte jetzt Vision dazu sagen, ich sag mal, da sind eine ganze Menge Unwirkbarkeiten drin.
Auf jeden Fall.
Also gerade so dieses, erstmal das Scheißteil da hoch kriegen, gut meinetwegen, da haben sie jetzt gezeigt, Rakete können sie landen, das können sie sicherlich auch ein dreimal so groß. Weil das Prinzip ist jetzt irgendwie verstanden und es ist relativ egal, wie groß das Ding ist. So einen Shuttle zu bauen, der halt wieder eintrittsfähig ist, hatten wir schon mal in den USA, war ganz schön teuer und war auch ganz schön federanfällig.
Na ja, wurde immer teurer. Zum Schluss, also die Zahl, die ich gehört hab, war, zum Schluss sind nur noch 40 Prozent der Masse des Shuttles tatsächlich wiederverwendet worden. Alles andere haben die nach der Landung abgebaut und in neu wieder herangebaut.
Also 40 Prozent der Masse wurde wieder verwendet. Oder sogar wenig.
Also nur vom Shuttle, nicht jetzt der Tank und die Raketen und dieser ganzen Kram, sondern nur vom Shuttle, 40 Prozent. Deswegen wurde das Ding ja auch so teuer, irgendwie eine halbe Milliarde pro Flug oder so.
Die haben so einen Mars-Eintritt, haben sie gezeigt. Aber haben sie auch einen Erdwiedereintritt gezeigt?
Es kommt ja noch besser, es kommt ja noch besser. Der Plan, den sie da haben, ist, sie landen auf dem Mars und nehmen eine kleine Fabrik mit, um mit den Elementen, die sie auf dem Mars haben, neuen Treibstoff herzustellen. Also sie haben keinen Treibstoff für den Rückflug dabei, sondern gehen davon aus, den Treibstoff vor Ort dann zu produzieren und da irgendwie mit Kryo und allem Drum und Dran in die Tanks bekommen. Ist auch eine geile Idee, aber ich glaube, ich gehöre nicht zu den ersten Kunden dieser Mission. Na gut, wieder Eintritt haben sie mit ihrer Dragon-Kapsel gezeigt. Das ist jetzt prinzipiell auch hinkriegen.
Wieso die Dragon-Kapsel, die verglüht?
Haben sie nicht irgendwie? Nein, sie haben noch eine mit Sample Return.
Die kommt doch mal runter. Die zu ISS fliegt. Die kommt wieder runter, wird mit Fallschirm ganz normal im Wasser. So wie immer halt.
Ist das so?
Ja, da sind ja auch die Ergebnisse der Tests drin und so.
Jaja, also ohne Passagiere, aber irgendwie mit Sample Return und so ein Zeug. Naja und irgendwie wollen sie also mit dem Booster Ding unten drunter, machen sie halt erst das Raumschiff in den Low Earth Orbit und dann wollen sie noch mal einen großen Tank hinterher schicken, dann rauen die, wuen die, dann pumpen sie irgendwie das Zeug rüber in das eigentliche Raumschiff und dann geht's los. So hab ich das verstanden. Also schon?
Ja, ich mein die machen ja auch wirklich, die haben ja echt Fortschritte am Start, kann man echt nicht anders sagen.
Aber wenn jetzt die Jungs der Besos von Virgin Intergalactic, oder wie sie heißen, wären die jetzt nervös.
Achso, naja gut, ich meine der Besos, der backt ja kleine Brötchen da mit seinem Teil.
Der wird eventuell auch umswitchen, wenn man auf große Brötchen, oder?
Ja, aber der macht bestenfalls eine flache Parabel und gut isst, ne?
Ja, Besos, weiß ich nicht, der ist nicht, der spinnt auch ein bisschen. Aber ich meine, der Elon, der ist ja richtig, der hat ja richtig...
Der spinnt ja mit Klasse.
Ja, genau, ich suchte gerade nach den Worten. Der hat irgendwie so eine voll professionelle Vollmeise. Also ich finde das auch gut. Und ehrlich gesagt, ich würde ihm wahrscheinlich auch mehr glauben, wenn er nur irgendetwas von den Redetalenten von Steve Jobs geerbt hätte.
Oh ja, der kann gar nicht reden.
Es ist so furchtbar, wie der sich da einen abstammelt und dann auch immer diese Videos, wo er dann in irgendeiner Scheißhalle steht und das klingt immer schon wie so direkt aus der Trash-Can heraus. Sorry, also wenn schon Visionen fürs 22. Jahrhundert, dann bitte aber auch in Dolby Surround und nicht so irgendwie aus einer Garage oder ich meine, das geht auch noch wirklich besser. Die Mikrofontechnik ist erfunden.
Der ist nicht so der gute, das muss ja schon nicht mehr ändern.
Vielleicht hat das auch Methode, aber ja, kann natürlich sein.
Methode? Was soll denn da die Methode sein?
Dass er da so hemsärmlich rüberkommt.
Man kann ja auch hemsärmlich rüberkommen und eine korrekte Mikrofonierung haben.
Aber ich muss sagen, dass ich Elon Musk noch lieber zuhöre als Tim Cook. Obwohl sich Tim Cook gesteigert hat, aber seine ersten Auftritte, die waren ja unerträglich, wenn man so zurückblickt.
Tja, er ist halt ein Operations Guy. Dafür hat er sich ganz gut entwickelt.
Das stimmt.
Aber ich mir so vorstelle, ähm, ähm, Apple würde eine Mars-Mission vorstellen, so mit dem aktuellen Personal.
Auch schwierig, ne?
Also solange es nicht dieser iTunes-Typ ist. Da ist der Vogel nochmal, ich vergess das immer wieder.
Oder hier dieser Makamoto von Nintendo.
Der geht ja nun gar nicht. Aber so Craig Federighi könnte mir das schon ganz gut verkaufen. Also der hätte schon klasse und ehrlich gesagt, ich leide nicht so sonderlich unter Tim Cook. Der ist halt nur, der hat aber auch so eine Bild in Langsamkeit. Ich glaub, das ist so dieses südamerikanische, wo kommt der her, Alabama, Arkansas, irgendwie so aus der Gegend.
Du meinst so, wie aus der Whisky-Werbung, wir haben viel Zeit mit unserem Whisky und dann, wo die Jungs da irgendwie Karten zocken auf dem Fass, so in die Richtung, glaube ich, könnte es gehen.
Genau.
Ja, ich finde bei Tim Cook auch die Begeisterung wirkt immer leicht aufgesetzt. Also Steve Jobs hat man die Begeisterung abgenommen, ob die jetzt echt war oder nicht, aber man hat sie eben abgenommen. Bei Tim Cook hat man immer so das Gefühl, er geht jetzt auf die Bühne und bemüht sich aus sich herauszugehen und das hat auch was Uncanny-mäßiges manchmal. Also, ja, du hast recht, er hat sich deutlich gesteigert, aber es ist trotzdem irgendwie creepy Tim.
Der ist schon zu Lebzeiten creepy, genau.
Aber das Design-Video der Rakete wäre mit Johnny Ive wahrscheinlich auch noch ein bisschen besser rüber gekommen.
Also wenn Johnny Ive das erklärt hätte?
Das würde auf jeden Fall gut aussehen.
Gut klingen.
Aber Johnny Ive, war der eigentlich schon mal auf der Bühne, außer in diesen Videos?
Nee, ne? Ich glaube, der will auch einfach nicht.
Ich glaube, der kann das auch nicht.
Oder ich glaube, irgendwann mal war er tatsächlich auf der Bühne.
Ich kann mich da zumindest nicht an erinnern.
Wer weiß, wie viele Tage die brauchen, um so ein Video mit ihm aufzunehmen, was hinterher nur zwei Minuten lang ist. Also das kann ja durchaus sein, dass das halt 20, 30, denkst.
Wirklichkeit hat ja nämlich einen Sprachfehler.
Nein, ich habe ihn auch schon in Interviews auf einer Bühne gesehen. So ist es nicht. Also es ist auch nicht so, dass er jetzt komplett faul wäre, Öffentlichkeit zu haben, aber aus irgendwelchen Gründen hält er sich halt aus diesem Ding raus. Aber es ist halt auch so bei... Ja, gut, das hätte er auch auf der Bühne machen können. Tja, also die ESA, die redet ja nicht nur vom Mars, die fliegt da ja auch hin. Von daher sind ja die Europäer da schon noch ein bisschen weiter. Schön, dass sie jetzt mal wieder ein paar Ziele formulieren hier in den USA.
Ja, der ESA-Typ, irgendein ESA-Typ hat ihn ja angekündigt, so als MC quasi. Ja, jetzt kommt hier Elon und der erzählt uns was.
Ein ESA-Typ war das?
Ach echt?
Welcher ESA-Typ war denn das?
Keine Ahnung. Einer von denen, die so fürchterlich Französisch sprechen. Also dieses französische Englisch.
Ja, hier ganz am Anfang?
Ja, ja, genau.
Ach echt?
Mach doch mal kurz an, dann hörst du es.
Französisch-Englisch.
Okay.
Also geht eigentlich bei dem noch?
Hören sie nix?
Ton müsstest du noch anmachen, wa?
Wie sie hören, hören sie nix?
Ja, warte mal, eine Sekunde. Eigentlich müsste doch... Ah, nee, warte mal, Entschuldigung, ich hatte das hier explizit ausgedreht.
Damit es nicht losplerzt.
Genau, damit es nicht losplerzt.
Ich bin Jean-Yves Le Gall, ich bin Präsident der CNES, der Franchtspace Agency und Präsident des International Astronautical Federation. International Astronautical Congress. SpaceX hat ein Nr. 1, z.B. als erste private Unternehmen, die Kargo von der International Space Station und die erste Einheit, eine Orbital-Buster zu landen, und die Schiffe aus dem Meer zu fahren.
Ich glaube, wenn er französisch gesprochen wäre, hätte ich mehr verstanden.
Aber hab ich zu viel versprochen? Nee, ne?
Noch sehr schön.
Nee, jetzt check ich das überhaupt erst, weil ich hab auch nur die Zusammenfassung gesehen, das ist halt auf so einer Konferenz, wo er spricht, und da haben sie nur das scheiß Akustik, und da hat er dann sozusagen präsentiert, und das ist halt vermutlich von der CNES ausgerichtet.
Der CNES SpeSex.
Ja, ich meine, wenn irgendeiner das mit dem Raketenstarten so richtig im Griff hat, dann ist es die CNES.
Na ja, die Russen schon auch, also.
Ne, bitte dich. Guck mal, was die Russen für Fails hatten in den letzten zehn Jahren. Also die hatten so richtig, richtig, richtig, richtig viele.
Sind das die Einzigen, die gerade zuverlässig zu ISS hochfliegen?
Nein.
Momentan fliegt niemand zuverlässig hoch.
Ja, die Astronauten.
Das ist ja das Wichtigste, oder?
Ne.
Ach so, die, die sind nicht so, die kann man ja ersetzen.
Nein, das ist auch wichtig, aber auch die Versorgung der Astronauten zum Beispiel ist nicht ganz unwichtig und das machen die Russen und das machen aber auch die Amerikaner und das haben halt auch die Europäer gemacht. Zusammen mit den Amerikanern. Also das europäische Modul war ja das am weitesten entwickelte... A, T, V, genau.
Ja, aber davon wurden auch noch 6 Stück gebaut oder so, oder 5 und jetzt ist es wieder eine Versenkung verschwunden.
Das stimmt nicht mit der Versenkung. Also es sind nur 5 gebaut worden, weil das war der Deal. Das sind ja immer diese Bata-Verträge. Das heißt, sie machen quasi internationale Kooperationen. Machen sie nicht, indem da Geld bezahlt wird, weil Geld volatil schwierig, sondern jeder muss sich halt kommitten, was Konkretes beizutragen und das Projekt zu stemmen. Die Europäer haben halt gesagt, okay, wir bauen jetzt mal hier eine Kapsel. Die macht Versorgung für die ISS, 5 Stück. Und der Teil war das erste autonom andockende System an der ISS. Also das erste Ding, wo der Computer vollständig den Andockprozess durchgeführt hat.
Auch bisher das einzige, ne?
Auch bisher das einzige.
Weil alle anderen wurden doch mit diesem Canadarm eingefangen.
Nee, normalerweise läuft das, das hängt ja ein bisschen davon ab.
Canadarm, Canadarm. Warum auch immer die, na egal.
Ja, also die paar, ich weiß jetzt nicht so ganz genau, ich glaub die japanischen Dinger auf jeden Fall und auch ein paar amerikanische Sachen. Bei der Dragon weiß ich es jetzt gerade nicht.
Doch, die wurde auch, die fliegt glaube ich nur bis auf ein paar Meter ran und dann wird sie eingefangen.
Aber doch nicht mit dem Arm.
Doch, ich glaube schon. Oder mit irgendeinem anderen System. Aber auf jeden Fall fliegt sie nicht autonom bis ganz ran.
Ich dachte sie doch genau da an, wo es ATV undockt. Und dann ist es einfach nur Manual Flight. Es geht sozusagen darum, dass es automatisch geht. Wie auch immer, diese ATV-Technik ist jetzt die Basis des Moduls, was die Amerikaner jetzt einsetzen werden, um dann auch selber wieder Astronauten zur ISS zu bringen. Auf Basis der ATV-Technik wird quasi das neue... was ist das? Ich weiß jetzt gerade nicht mehr. Nicht Kolumbus, irgendwie anders.
Kolumbus war das Forschungsding?
Ja, das ist ein Forschungssegment, deswegen kann es das nicht sein. Habe ich jetzt gerade irgendwie... fällt mir noch ein. Ja, so, aber die CNES macht halt...
Was ist die CNES?
Das ist die französische Raumfahrtbehörde.
Weil es hört sich so an wie bei den Israelis.
Das ist ein bisschen was anderes. Das ist ein Parlament. CNES ist so was wie DLR.
Das ist richtig mit CNES oder was?
Und die fahren halt unter anderem Kuro. Weil das ist ja in Frankreich, also in französisch Guiana.
Eine gemeindete Kolonie.
Das ist halt ein Departement von der Frankreichischen Gründnation. Und die starten halt einfach da seit, seit wann machen die das? 20 Jahren?
Nicht 70er oder so schon?
Länger schon, 30 Jahre. Auf jeden Fall. Die hatten halt mal einen Fail mit Division bei Zero Error. Da ist ihnen irgendwie eine hochgegangen.
Ja, und da haben sie aber irgendwie die falsche Software in die Rakete reingespielt. Das war, glaube ich, das Problem.
Ja, es war halt irgendwie ein Fuck-up. Und du hast halt schon mal Fuck-ups. Aber seit Jahren hörst du halt nichts davon, weil das quasi in der öffentlichen Wahrnehmung so geräuschlos ist, weil die starten einfach, deliveren ihren Payload und fertig. Und das machen die einfach da wie am Schnürchen. Und es gibt einfach keine Unfälle, keine Ausfälle, keine Explosionen, nichts. Es ist einfach clean. Da mag im Einzelnen irgendwo auch mal was schiefgehen, was vielleicht unerwartete Kosten aufwirft. Das weiß ich nicht, aber zumindest haben sie jetzt nicht so klassische Fails wie unter anderem SpaceX, den ja gerade mal wieder die Rakete sogar noch vor dem Start explodiert.
Die es mit dem Tanken nicht hingekriegt haben.
Ja, so. Und das ist halt auch schon...
Aber sie wissen immer noch nicht, was das war, ne?
Das weiß ich nicht. Irgendein Bauteil wird halt mal wieder scheiße drauf gewesen sein. Aber das sind halt... Ich meine, das ist ja auch nicht... Lass jetzt gar nicht belachen. Das passiert halt. Du baust halt eine neue Technologie auf und dann failst die halt einfach. Und du musst halt irgendwie einen Failover am Start haben. Du musst halt irgendwie finanziell das weiter stemmen können. Wobei das jetzt wohl ganz schön teuer war für SpaceX, die Nummer. Und ja, jetzt muss man mal sehen, wie die da aufstehen. Und die Russen haben schon glaube ich seit 20 Jahren keine Deep Space Missionen mehr losgeschickt bekommen. Die letzte, die sie starten wollten, ging zum Mars. Und die sind halt auch auf dem Launchpad irgendwie abgeraucht. Nö, die ist dann irgendwie im Orbit abgegeigt.
Ah ja, stimmt. Übrigens zu dem Thema, es gibt einen wunderbaren Podcast für alle, die sich für sowas interessieren. Der heißt Space Rocket History. Der Typ, der spricht ein bisschen merkwürdiges Englisch, weil er auch irgendwie so ein Südstaatler ist. Podcast, genau. Und da gibt's also, ich find ja die ganzen Folgen, wo es um die russischen Missionen geht, verdammt interessant. Besonders diese vorhin schon erwähnte N1, mit denen die Sowjets zum Mond fliegen wollten. Die Geschichte ist einfach wunderbar, wie sie dieses Ding versucht haben, zum Fliegen zu kriegen. Also, und er fängt, der fängt auch wirklich im Urschleim an.
Ich zeig mal dem Dennis gerade mal die Reuspertaste, damit er mit seinem Mikrofon richtig gehen kann.
Er fängt tatsächlich im Urschleim an, irgendwie bei den Chinesen und den alten Griechen. Und kommt dann auch relativ schnell so zu den deutschen Anfängen, V2, V1 und solche Sachen. Das ist ganz furchtbar, wie er das ausspricht. Also gerade so diese deutschen Namen und Bezeichnungen. Aber es sind sehr, sehr spannende Sachen dabei. Ein bisschen anstrengend ist er, dass er irgendwie von jedem einzelnen Astronaut und Kosmonaut irgendwie in epischer Länge noch den Lebenslauf bespricht und so. Aber die technischen Sachen sind schon sehr spannend. Da lohnt es sich wirklich mal reinzuhören, wenn man sich für sowas interessiert.
Er redet jetzt echt über jede Mission?
Ja, über jede einzelne und teilweise über mehrere Folgen. Leider ist der Feed irgendwie nur die letzten paar Söhne zu viel. Und den Rest muss man auf der Webseite sich anhören.
Ja, wenn du mal Potlar verwendet hättest und nicht dieses bekloppte Powerpress nachdem es hier schon wieder aussieht.
Mach das mal. Schlimm. Ach ja, und er hat immer so einen länglichen Ausgangsgelaberzeug. Das kann man gleich überspringen. In den späteren Folgen beginnt er die sowjetischen Episoden immer mit der sowjetischen Nationalhymne. Und natürlich mit der amerikanischen Nationalhymne. Das ist irgendwie ein bisschen cheesy an einigen Stellen, aber sehr gut.
Gibt es eigentlich irgendeine Rakete oder eine Treiberstufe, wo ja auch immer das heißt, was wieder zurück in die Erde kommt, was sich dreht, damit sich die Hitze auf der Fläche verteilt, aufs ganze Raumschiff, sag ich jetzt mal. Also beim Shuttle, das kam noch mal runter, an dem ist noch mal die Spitze weggeglüht oder die Unterseite.
Der Shuttle selber hat, da hab ich auch mal was zugehört, hat Schlangenlinien geflogen. Beim Re-Entry um die Hitze immer wieder auf die eine, dann die rechte, dann die andere Seite.
Das ist ja auch drehen komplett oder? Bei dem Ding jetzt vielleicht schlecht wegen, weil es ja schon so ein bisschen flüchelmäßig runterkommt, aber bei diesem Dildo da, der relativ gleich aussieht, der könnte ja so drehen reinkommen einfach.
Nee, macht er auch nicht. Also sah nicht aus, so in dem Video war das auch ganz normal flach rein.
Ach so, das würde schon helfen von der Hitzeverteilung, oder?
Da muss er halt auch noch überall noch mehr Hitzeschild und noch mehr Hitzepfständigkeit. Nee, du willst ja vielleicht auch mal irgendwo noch mal ein Fenster haben oder so was.
Also die meisten Kapseln, die haben ja quasi am Boden hier dickes Hitzeschild, was ja im Prinzip nur ein Stoff ist, der nicht gut Wärme leitet, aber sich Schicht für Schicht runterschmelzen lässt. Bis du dann langsam genug bist, dass es nicht mehr so heiß ist.
Bei der Schwärmschatte, da war das doch so scheiße, haben die das auch mehr oder weniger ausgetauscht nach jedem Flug, oder die ganzen Kacheln, die sind alle abgefallen.
Jaja, das gehört zu den 40 Prozent wiederverwendete Masse dazu, die ich meinte. Also die Triebwerke haben sie sowieso immer irgendwie rotiert. Also Triebwerke wurden immer alle ausgebaut. Und dann kamen sie auf den Teststand und die Frischen haben sie wieder eingebaut. Und dann haben sie irgendwie... Ja, aber es gibt auch in diesem Space Rocket History gab es eine sowjetische Kapsel, die... Da war ja irgendwie... Die Kapsel war ja irgendwie mit dem Boden an so einer Art Versorgungszylinder dran. Und dann gab es eine Mission, da hat sich bei der Landung der Versorgungszylinder nicht von der Kapsel richtig gelöst. Und dann ist die Nase voran eingetreten. Und wer fast weggeglüht, nur als es dann heißer wurde, ist dieses komische Versorgungsdingens dann doch abgegangen. Und dann hat sich das Teil umgedreht. Und der Kosmonaut, der wurde erst fast gebraten. Und dann ist er irgendwo falsch runtergekommen, mitten im tiefsten Schnee gelandet. Fenster war nicht mehr in Ordnung, ist da aus dem Ding raus, bei minus sonst wie Grad und hat sich irgendwie versucht, ins nächste Dorf bei irgendwelchen Eskimos zu retten und so weiter. Also eine ganz abstruse Geschichte. Der hat irgendwie auch alle Zähne dabei verloren und so. Aber dass das überhaupt überlebt hat. Die im Kontrollzentrum, die haben nur gehört, jetzt bricht der Funk ab, es stimmt irgendwas nicht, haben sie erstmal einen Hut rumgehen lassen, weil die alle nicht mehr daran geglaubt haben, dass sie ihn wiedersehen.
Gut, soviel zum Thema Weltraum. Wollen wir über Sport reden?
Ich war ein bisschen shoppen. Da ich ja irgendwann doch angefangen habe zu laufen, aus irgendwelchen Gründen, obwohl ich dachte, laufen wäre nie so meins, habe ich mir natürlich gedacht, da brauche ich auch noch eine Uhr dafür. Ziehe mir schön die Wegstrecke auf. Dafür habe ich nicht das passende Problem, tut mir leid.
Ich wollte nur ein bisschen rumgiften.
Apple-Geräte, für die hat man nicht das Problem. Für die hat man einfach die Lust, sie zu kaufen.
Da fehlt mir die Lust, das Ding zu haben. Na gut. Mir sind halt mehrere Sachen aufgefallen. Ich wollte einen GPS-Tracker schon länger haben, fürs Wandern eigentlich. Aber so ein reiner GPS-Tracker ist echt ganz schön teuer. Da dachte ich mir so, ach nee, dann kaufst du dir das halt nicht. Mit dem Laufen dachte man sich so, vielleicht wäre es irgendwie ganz nett, die Strecke, die man läuft, aufzunehmen. Und auch so zu sehen.
Wofür eigentlich?
Dass ich Sport mache?
Also ich bin ja Motorradfahrer und da gibt es auch, da kann man sich halt seine Strecken aufzeichnen lassen. Habe ich einmal gemacht, weil ich wissen wollte, ob es geht. Aber ja, man braucht das für nix, diese Strecke danach.
Beim Laufen will ich einfach nur wissen, wie viel Kilometer, aber beim Wandern nicht. Beim Wandern nehme ich zwar meistens die Strecke, die vorgegeben ist, oder was die Beschilderung während der Trails sagt. Aber wenn du dann doch mal links und rechts davon dich bewegst, finde ich das schon ganz cool, wenn man in größeren Strecken läuft, das auch noch mal nachzuverfolgen.
Das geht ja dann auch in Kombination mit so etwas wie Pulsmessung, dass du danach auch sehen kannst, welcher Teil der Strecke hat dich wie sehr belastet.
Also beim Wandern weiß ich noch nicht, ob ich, also ich habe keinen Pulsmesser über die Uhr drin, ich habe einen Herzfrequenz-Sensor, einen Brustgurt. Eine Polar M400. Ne, es ist die billige Variante, die ich aufgrund der wirklich sehr schönen Farbe für 120 Euro geschossen habe. So ein Normalpress ist glaube ich mit Brustgurt zwischen 140-150 bis 200 hoch.
Weil die Farbe so schön war, durftest du weniger bezahlen?
Keine Ahnung. Es ist mir auch bei den iPhones aber schon einige Male aufgefallen, dass diese hässlichen Gold, wie ich jetzt eins Gold habe, und Rose Gold meistens günstiger sind. Ja, aber ich gucke da hinten eh nicht drauf.
Was?
Aber nicht im Wiederverkauf.
Das weiß ich nicht.
Vielleicht.
Wenn man sich auf so verschiedenen Preisvergleichsportalen geschaut hat, waren die halt meistens günstiger. Ich weiß nicht warum. Jedenfalls bei dieser Uhr war es der Fall, dass einige relativ günstig waren. Und da ich Freunde habe, die sich auch so auf Marathon mit solchen Uhren vorbereiten, dachte ich mir so, ok, kaufen wir mal eine Polaruhr.
Kein Raum mehr für Interpretationen.
Das ist pink, das sieht für mich eher aus wie...
Schweinchenrosa, können wir es auch. Also so eine Mischung aus Pink und Schweinchenrosa.
Schweinchenrosa trifft es auch nicht so richtig.
Ist mir auch manchmal schon ein bisschen unangenehm, ich hab jetzt auch so pinkische Laufschuhe und ne pinkische Leggings. Und in der Tat sogar noch ein pinkes Shirt. Nee, keine Angst. Mädchen, hihihi.
Wo du doch sonst immer so stilsicher gekleidet bist.
Ach, deswegen, ist auch die Gesellschaft.
Wo du doch sonst immer so stilsicher gekleidet bist, Letty.
Ja, das ist richtig, weil ich sonst nur Schwarz trage. Aber Leggings in der Tat dürfen bei mir sehr bunt sein. Nicht nur zum Laufen, dafür hab ich sie eigentlich nicht gekauft. Und Schuhe finde ich in der Tat, so Sportschuhe, so relativ schrille schon geil. Das fand ich im Laden auch natürlich super. Also ich meinte so, ja Farbe, so schrille wie es geht. Mach mal die Uhr bitte. Also die hat irgendwie super viele Funktionen, mit der sie irgendwie daherkommt. Dass du dich wirklich auf den Marathon mit den Uhren vorbereiten kannst. Dass die dir so einen Trainingsplan auch vorgeben. Aber derzeit, ich nutze die eigentlich nur, um die Strecken aufzuzeichnen, Herzfrequenz mir anzuschauen, gerade so auch so ein bisschen die Strecke zu analysieren, wo bin ich langsam gelaufen. Dann weiß ich manchmal ja auch, wenn ich drauf gucke, ah ok, Straße überquert.
Und Puls misst das Ding nicht, deswegen hast du diesen Brustgurt.
Ja, warum ist ja nicht einfach der Pulsmesser noch direkt in der Uhr?
Was kostet der Brustgurt extra?
Ich glaube bei denen direkt 60. Du kannst aber jeden nehmen. Bluetooth oder ist das irgendwie? Du kannst halt auch jeden X-Beliebigen nehmen, außer die von Garmin glaube ich. Die haben irgendeinen Sonderfufeil, wie die sich kopplen.
Gibt es auch iPhones für Android oder iPhone oder so, dass man die auch mit was anderem auslesen kann?
Die Daten kannst du dir komplett runterladen bei dem Portal.
Nehmen wir dann der Gurt.
Das habe ich mich schon gefragt, das will ich mal ausprobieren. Theoretisch müsste das doch mit der Batch gehen, oder? Mit der Radio-Batch? Aber, weiß ich nicht, müsste man mal gucken. Das würde mich interessieren, weil uns ist nämlich so ein bisschen die Frage aufgekommen, wenn es schon so nah ist, so am Körper, ob man nicht auch sogar die Atemzüge damit noch auslesen könnte. Was ja dann relativ interessant wird, wenn du das vergleichst dann auch noch. Wie deine Atmung so ist. Ja, also eine Freundin meinte, dass das sehr, sehr... Also wenn man eh schon die Herzfrequenz und das alles hatten, dass ja auch sehr nah am Brustgut, logischerweise auch an der Lunge sitzt, sollte man das hinbekommen.
Ich hätte noch so eine Tankanzeige dabei, die mir sagt, wie viele Kilometer ich jetzt noch laufen kann.
Das gibt es außerdem, dass du dir so die Tankanzeige sofort definierst. Oder aber der nächste Späti kommt dann so und so viele Meter an. Du kannst dir das nächste Bier schnappen. In der Tat habe ich heute gelesen, dass es diese Uhr, also ebenso diese GPS-Funktion hat. Und wenn du dich ein bisschen so in deinem Hood verlaufen hast beim Laufen, gibt es wohl eine Funktion, die dich zu deinem Startpunkt zurückbringt. Und die will ich unbedingt ausprobieren. Das finde ich interessant.
Aha, wie denn?
Also, das ist eine gute Frage. Das wird sicherlich die GPS-Sachen dahinter nutzen, die es auch abgespeichert hat.
Ja, aber sich im Prenzlauer Berg zu verlaufen, ist jetzt eher schwierig, oder?
Nee, aber ich will die Uhr nach Quito zum Beispiel mitnehmen, wenn ich in Quito bin und in Quito laufen. Ich meine, 2800 Höhenmeter muss man mal ausprobiert haben beim Laufen.
Die läufst ja nicht hoch, du bist ja schon oben hin.
Ja, trotzdem. Das musst du erstmal ausprobieren, da oben zu laufen.
Ja, ist die Luft ein bisschen dünner, aber das passt sich anders, das machen alle Sportler.
Ja, aber kommt natürlich auch an, ob es feucht ist oder so. Aber, ich mein...
Und wie ist die Usability? Ich meine, ich hab ja jetzt auch gerade mit WatchOS 3 teste ich jetzt auch gerade mal wieder so alles durch, wie sich die Uhr so als Sportpartner bewährt.
Das ist aber jetzt noch die alte Series Null, ne?
Genau.
Series Null, genau.
So wird die jetzt genannt.
Das ist nicht die schlechteste Bezeichnung dafür.
Also ich benutze einfach die eingebaute whatever und bin damit für meine Zwecke gut genug.
Ich laufe halt nicht mit.
Du machst halt kein GPS-Tracking, oder?
Na, mach das Phone. Und das macht's gut genug.
Das Phone macht das?
Ja, natürlich.
Wo, wie, was? Wo, wie, wo?
Der Phone hat ja GPS. Also du musst es halt mit haben.
Ich hab's ja immer mit.
Mit der neun Uhr muss man's ja nicht mehr mit haben.
Na, wenn du, wenn du... Ach Gottchen, wie heißt das? Diese Sports... Diese komischen Sportdingens, dieses...
Aktivität.
Aktivität, genau. Da drückst du drauf. Bei mir ist das ja immer Rad Outdoor.
Ja.
Dann drück ich da drauf, dann zählt da 3, 2, 1 und dann geht's los.
Ja, aber wo ist die Karte? Ah, hier.
Die Karte ist Christe hinterher, in dem... Stimmt.... in diesem Aktivitäts-Dings unten kriegst du dann die rote. Bei mir hat das jetzt 3 Tage nicht funktioniert, weil ich irgendwie schlauerweise die nächste Beta-Version auf die Spur Uhr gespielt habe, aber die nicht auf dem Phone hatte. Aber... Also für meine Zwecke ist das gut genug.
und korreliert der dann auch? der korreliert dann nicht den Puls, oder? Davon sehe ich jetzt hier nichts.
Das kann sein, dass es nicht tut, ja.
Ja, weil das ist ja so, sagen wir mal, das eigentliche Feature. Also wo ich lang gelaufen bin, das weiß ich ja im Zweifelsfall noch selber. Aber man will ja auch wissen, wie gut es einem ging. So. Aber warte mal, das ist doch jetzt echt interessant. Na ja, schon, klar. Weil ich meine, über die Belastung kannst du ja deine Aussage über deinen Trainingszustand fällen.
Ich weiß nicht, kann ich... Tim, kann ich hier auf dem Monitor was scheren? Ich meine, dann kann ich euch mal die Trainingsanzeige auch zeigen. Also von so einem Trainings-Run.
Luftspiel einschalten.
Ich überleg grad, wo es war.
Ja, leider treten die Apple-Aktivitäten nicht in Rantestik auf. Aber Brustgurt, mal echt.
Bin ich jetzt gerade im falschen Netz? Ich sehe deinen Airplay nicht.
Wahrscheinlich.
Was?
Die Weiß. Willst du jetzt nicht das Passwort durch den... Achso, du kannst doch einfach Kabel reinstecken. Weißt du auch, hier Ethernet und so.
Hier ist doch, hier ist doch, hier bist du auch bestimmt.
Aber das WLAN-Passwort ist doch da oben oder nicht?
Haben wir auch einen Adapter?
Nee, das ist für Public.
Ist das nicht das gleiche?
Da muss ich wohl mal kurz hier bei mir aussteppen.
Nee, ich hab ja noch mehr Adapter. So ist es ja nicht.
Du kannst ja den mal nehmen, während Tim versucht neue Adapter zu finden.
Du kannst ja nicht das Passwort kurz im Chat mal rüber schieben, ne?
Technik.
Die begeistert.
Wahrscheinlich wird mir gleich vor Freude auch der Rechner wieder abstürzen, wenn ich hier auf das Airplay zugreifen will.
Ich danke dir.
Funktioniert ja auch alles besser über iEDaNet, weißt du auch, wie das ist.
Meister EDaNet.
So, dann mal her mit dem Luftspiel. Ich muss eh nochmal testen, ob das funktioniert. Ich hab hier gerade meinen Apple TV ausgetauscht.
Hast du jetzt einen aktuellen Apple TV?
Nee, jetzt hab ich den aktuellen bei mir in die Wohnung reingetan, weil...
Können wir Fenster ein bisschen ranmachen, das zieht so kalt hier unten durch irgendwie.
Ja, komischerweise hab ich immer noch keine Airplay-Option.
Kannst du das auch einfach beschreiben, die Hörer können es ja sowieso nicht sehen.
Ich halte es halt einfach falsch. Können wir ein Screenshot davon machen. Nee, aber es ist irgendwie ganz nett, so die Herzfrequenz zu sehen, in welchem Herzfrequenz-Bereich man so unterwegs ist und wie sich halt auch so, also ich laufe jetzt irgendwie erst einen Monat, aber wie sich das halt schon so ein bisschen konstanter alles einpegelt nach einer Zeit. Das ist irgendwie ganz nett. Ja, und ich laufe halt nicht mit Telefon, also ich hab maximal die Uhr und den Schlüssel dabei und das war's. Mehr würde ich mit mir halt auch nicht rumschleppen müssen.
Ist mir das schonmal hier, dass man ja auch hier mit dem Phone, mit der Flitzlampe und der Kamera seinen Puls messen kann?
Ja, aber nicht mit Bordmitteln, da brauchst du dann zusätzliche Anbieter.
Da brauchst du dann noch eine App für, ja.
Ja, das funktioniert aber auch noch.
83, uiuiuiui.
Woll ich, man könnte ja mal hier Vergleichsmessungen machen.
Achso, du hältst jetzt einfach deinen Finger hinten auf die LED.
Auf die LED, die Kamera nimmt auf und nimmt den Farbunterschied im Rot, weil mehr, weil das Blut ja immer so in den Zügen kommt, im Puls halt. Ich hab hier diese Health Mate, die von dieser Withings Companies, wo ich meine Waage von habe.
Ah, Gesundheitsmarte.
Das fehlt noch im Angebot der süßen, koffeinhaltigen Getränke, die Gesundheitsmarte.
Also ich verstehe das mit dem Brustgurt nicht. Man kann auch irgendwie den Puls auch wunderbar...
Die Genauigkeit ist aber nicht dieselbe. Dazu gibt es sogar wissenschaftliche Paper. Nee, das habe ich letztens aber darauf verwiesen gesehen. Also ich meine, warum soll ich mir eine Uhr kaufen, die niemand meiner ernsthaften Sportfreunde nutzt, also die wirklich ernsthaft damit trainieren? Ich kaufe mir keine Fashion-Uhr. Nee, für die Läufer, die wirklich Marathon und alles laufen, die laufen definitiv mit Uhr. Damit du halt weißt, wann du wieder deine...
Du hast ja auch Pace-Maker, damit man nicht zu schnell ist und nicht zu langsam und so.
Auch als normaler Läufer. Du hast immer deine Uhr dabei, damit du eben genau weißt, wann gehst du runter mit der Geschwindigkeit, damit sich dein Puls noch ein bisschen wieder in den Herz weckt, wenn es ein bisschen runtergeht.
Das meine ich ja mit Pace-Maker, also dass die Uhr den Speed vorgibt, damit man genau weiß, jetzt nicht zu schnell, nicht zu langsam.
Kannst du bei der machen.
Die brauchen doch so beim Marathon auch, dass sie nicht vor Ausgaben schon am Anfang und das kann man ja manchmal schwer einschätzen.
Genau, das kannst du mit der alles machen. Also das habe ich noch nicht alles ausprobiert, ein paar Sachen schon, aber irgendwie hier mir einzubilden, dass ich irgendwie in diesen nicht in den höchsten Herzfrequenzbereich reingehe. Dann kannst du das halt piepen lassen, wenn du in diesen Bereich reinkommst. Also hat das dann ständig gepiept und das willst du dann auch nicht haben. Da war ich halt einfach noch nicht gut trainiert genug dafür. Aber es ist irgendwie ganz nett und was mir aber aufgefallen ist, also ich trage halt eh keine Uhren und ich habe direkt erst mal eine Abdruckstelle davon bekommen. Also die geht auch nicht so richtig weg gerade. Ich weiß nicht. Ich habe hier so ein paar Druckstellen.
Hornhaut an der Hand Innenseite.
Hornhaut habe ich nur auf den Fingern vom Klettern.
Also du würdest das auf jeden Fall empfehlen.
Ja, ich finde das spannend. Hier wurde auch gerade schon im Chat geschrieben, dass man über die Android-App wohl ganz viele der Daten sehen kann, die wirklich rauskommen, weil mehr als nur die Herzfrequenz wohl rausfällt. Ah, und da gibt es auch noch eins für den App Store. Wunderbar. Na das muss ich mir mal anschauen. Also ich find's sehr spannend auf jeden Fall. Ich hab's auch mal versucht so wirklich als Activity Logger so den ganzen Tag das Ding zu tragen und oh Gott, ich mag Uhren nicht. Das war noch nie so mein Device und...
Aber du hast sie ja eh um.
Nee, die hab ich zum Laufen nur um. Ja, aber für mehr will ich sie nicht tragen. Also dann merk ich einfach, dass das atmet weh und ich stoß da auch ständig irgendwo ran. Also wahrscheinlich würde meine mehr beim Apple Support liegen, damit sie ständig repariert wird.
Mich musst du erstmal schlagen.
Ja, das stimmt, das ist richtig.
Das ist ja jetzt auch schon die dritte.
Apollo 3.
Apollo 3?
Nein, kann man ja hochzählen, solange bis es dann mal klappt, quasi.
Hatt ich eigentlich in der letzten Sendung mein iPhone, da war es gerade eingeschickt, ne?
Du hattest da irgendwie einen anderes, so lang oder wie war das?
Genau.
Und jetzt hast du schon wieder, oder?
Ich hab mein iPhone SE wieder. Und? Es ist bemerkenswert zu sehen, was so 5, 5, 5, 5S, 6, 6S, 3 Generationen iPhone so ausmachen.
Achso zwischen dem 5 und dem 5 SE?
Ja, also das ist mit der App, was du meinst. Ja, man kann auf so einem iPhone 5 einfach, da kannst du schon gar nicht mehr mit arbeiten. Also zwar so vom User Interface geht das gerade irgendwie so noch, aber so dieser Speicherhunger der Apps, der ist so dermaßen angewachsen, dass einfach die Chance, dass das Programm schon wieder gekillt ist, wenn du es nur einmal in der Woche legst, so hoch ist, dass du irgendwie gar nicht mehr mit arbeiten kannst und so bestimmte richtig schlecht programmierte Apps kommen irgendwie auch gar nicht mehr hoch.
Hast du da ein iOS 10 draufgemacht?
Ich habe da ein iOS 10 draufgemacht, ja.
Das ist natürlich auch sportlich, aber ja, warum?
Ich habe halt aus dem Backup, was sollte ich tun?
Nein, nein, das ist ja nur trotzdem sportlich.
Ja, wahrscheinlich ist es sportlich. Man könnte ja auch mal sein, dass diese neuen iOS ein bisschen schneller sind. Ich fand das jetzt vom iOS her eigentlich auch okay, aber es war halt von den Apps eigentlich eher total schwer, aber jetzt bin ich wieder ein Happy SE User und finde es super.
Ich finde es macht ein bisschen Sehenscheiden, die Entzündung des iPhones.
Das kann ich ja nicht verstehen. Wovon redest du?
Ich auch nicht.
Ich habe das iPhone irgendwie mal zwei Tage benutzt und habe versucht, auf mein Schnittchen zu verzichten. Und ich habe vom Halten.
Schnittchen?
Das ist Blackberry. Es hat halt einen Namen.
Haben deine Geräte einen Namen?
Schnittchen hat einen Namen, ja. Geräte, die ich liebe, schon.
Dein iPhone heißt einfach nur iPhone, oder wie?
So heißt dein iPhone?
Gut, also noch was nachzutragen zum Thema Sport?
Nein, würde ich jetzt nicht so sagen. Mich würde interessieren auch mal, was ich testen würde, ist die Uhr. Vielleicht würde ich sie mal zum Klettern mitnehmen wollen, um da so ein bisschen zu checken, was ich so für Herzfrequenzen beim Klettern habe. Das würde mich mal interessieren, aber die ist ja wahnsinnig im Weg. Da kann man sie nicht tragen, muss man sie irgendwo festmachen. Ich hab's beim Yoga gemerkt.
Ja, beim Klettern, wenn du das am Handklenk hast, vor allem wenn du auch dann irgendwo hängen bleibst.
Ja, genau. Selbst beim Yoga nervt es schon ohne Ende.
Beim Yoga?
Ja.
Du trägst die Polaruhr beim Yoga.
Wenn ich mich dehne vor dem Laufen, so dehne, ein bisschen Yoga machen.
Dann misst es auch noch deine Dehnung?
Nee, dann misse ich noch. Wie weit man im Spagat sitzen kann und überhaupt. Nee, ich hab's halt einfach, trage ich sie dann meistens im Brustgurz, um zu sehen, wie so die Herzfrequenz einfach ist. Also es ist gerade einfach nur spannend, so Kurven zu verfolgen.
Du bist einfach kurvengeil. Ich bin kurvengeil. Du bist ja so eine Chart-Lady irgendwie. Du nimmst ja diese Rohdaten dann auch und visualisierst sie mal selber ein bisschen?
Ich bin so ein bisschen geneigt, das auch mal zu machen. Auch gerade so vielleicht mal die Daten zu analysieren, wenn man so mal wirklich so ein Jahr gelaufen ist. Ich würde mich echt interessieren, die Daten mal zu analysieren, ob man so Muster erkennt in den Daten, die man so vom Laufen her hat. Ob das auch auf die Strecke zurückzuführen ist, oder ob du aber immer sagen kannst, bei Kilometer 5, da bricht sie jedes Mal aus Neue ein. Also das würde mich mal interessieren, ob du so Daten sehen kannst.
Ja, mach mal.
Aber wie gesagt, da muss ich erstmal ein bisschen laufen und dran bleiben.
Erstmal ein paar Daten generieren.
Erstmal ein paar Daten generieren und visualisieren, ja. Und was halt auch, also beim Wandern auf jeden Fall will ich das nächstes Jahr ausprobieren. Wie sie sich da schlägt auch von der Akkulaufzeit. Also ich hab's jetzt noch nicht wieder geladen. Ich hab sie seit dem 9. September jetzt, glaube ich, also 20 Tage fast in Gebrauch und hab sie noch nicht wieder geladen. Ist erstmal schon mal ganz cool, dass sie scheinbar eine gute Akkulaufzeit hat. Also gerade wenn du beim Wandern unterwegs bist und irgendwie neun Stunden, du läufst keine neun Stunden. Aber so bis zu sieben läuft man ja doch manchmal. Das würde mich mal interessieren, wie sie dann...
Ja, vor allem wenn sie dauerhaft GPS macht.
Genau, wenn sie dauerhaft GPS macht.
Also da bin ich mir noch nicht so sicher, ob das so sehr viel schlechter ist als bei der Apple Watch.
Naja, ich hab ja bei meinen Telefonen auch immer auf Flugmodus, wenn ich laufe. Also ich will halt nicht die ganzen Scheiße um mich haben. Also ganze Notification hier und da.
Weil du ja eigentlich im Tiefflug unterwegs bist.
Ich bin einfach genau im Tiefflug unterwegs.
Für ein iPhone reicht es noch nicht, aber du bist ausreichend in der Lage, dir so einen Schub zu geben, dass du dir irgendwie geile Gadgets für Sport kaufst. Du machst sogar Sportarten, von denen du eigentlich dachtest, dass du sie nicht machen würdest.
Ja, Laufen definitiv.
Ja, ist auch gar nicht so schlecht, Laufen.
Ich hab gerade ein bisschen Knieschmerzen, aber man wird halt älter. Nee, aber Laufen macht grad Spaß. Und man muss sich an keine soziale Gruppe binden, um sich zu motivieren.
Das ist allerdings ein Riesenpunkt.
Und Timme, am Samstag war ja hier Inlineskatermarathon oder sowas, ne? Ah ja. Warst du auch nicht dabei, ne?
Nee, war ich nicht dabei.
Das wär aber mal interessant.
Ich war mal dabei, also ich bin schon mehrere Male Inlineskatermarathon gelaufen. Ich glaub insgesamt drei oder vier Mal. Aber das letzte Mal schon eine Weile her.
Ist eigentlich der Skatermarathon auch nur die 42 Kilometer?
Ja. Exakt die gleiche Strecke, ja? In Berlin ist es nicht exakt dieselbe Strecke, sondern es sind so zwei, drei Straßenführungen anders. Wegen Skaterbedarf. Wegen des Bodens vermutlich. Also der Bodenbelagsqualität. Aber ansonsten ist die Distanz natürlich dieselbe. Und für Skaten ist es eine geile Distanz. 42 Kilometer ist echt super. Ich hab das auch gerne gemacht. Ich hab das auch ganz gut hinbekommen seiner Zeit. Ich glaub, meine beste Zeit war 1,35. Das ist jetzt nicht außergewöhnlich. Aber jetzt ordentlich muss man sich jetzt nicht verschämen. Das würde ich jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht nochmal erreichen. Außerdem hab ich neulich beim Umzug festgestellt, dass meine Inline-Skates weg sind.
Ich hab gesehen, dass die ja ihre Rollen alle umgestellt haben. Also früher waren ja anscheinend vier Rollen angesagt. Jetzt fahren die alle auf drei Rollen und die sind viel größer. Die sehen ja Reibungen und so und durch die größeren Rollen bessere Rolleigenschaften.
Ja, ich hatte ja noch einen Fünfer.
Fünfer, das ist gar nicht mehr angesagt. Fünfer hab ich gar nicht gesehen, glaub ich. Die vorne hatten alle Dreier die Profis und hinten kamen dann immer mehr Vierer und ganz am Ende waren nur noch Vierer.
Ja, kann schon sein. Ich find aber die Fünfer sehen geiler aus.
Ja, aber die Rollen sind zu klein, das ist nicht so gut.
Na, du hast ja dann immer ein Platzproblem, musstest ja auch noch unter Fuß kriegen.
Aber Vierer habe ich auf jeden Fall in Großaschang gesehen.
Das war dann der erste Trend. Also erst gab's die Vierer normal, dann gab's die Fünfer für die Skater, die halt einfach längere Kufe brauchten, haben sie halt einfach noch eine Rolle dazugenommen. Und dann kamen sie mit den großen Viererrollen. Und der Trend zu Dreier, wobei Dreier muss ich sagen, also ich weiß nicht, ob ich mir einen Dreier holen würde, dann schon eher große Vierer. Weil klar, weniger Reibung, kann ich alles verstehen, super. Aber das heißt halt, du hast auch noch weniger Führung nach vorne. Also dieser weniger Bodenkontakt bedeutet ja auch, dass du sozusagen weniger Spurführung hast.
Weniger Bodenkontakt oder weil sozusagen deine, die Länge vom ersten Rad bis zum letzten kürzer ist?
Die ist nicht unbedingt kürzer, weil die Rollen sind ja größer. Aber du hast halt weniger Kontaktpunkte. Das heißt, du hast dann eben auch weniger Bodenhaftung. Und ich hätte so ein bisschen Bedenken, dass man da schneller los eiert. Aber da kann ich mich nicht wirklich so zu äußern. Das scheint ja offensichtlich trotzdem zu funktionieren, wenn so viele Leute das benutzen.
Wie gesagt, umso größer die Rollen sind, umso besser rollt sich das ab. Eigentlich sollte man, das gibt es ja irgendwie so Tests bei Autos, eigentlich müsste man da auch viel größere Reifen nehmen und dafür schmaler, weil das rollt besser ab und verbraucht viel weniger Energie. Also jedes kleinste Millimeter Hindernis muss ja überrollt werden. Und umso größer dein Reifen ist, umso besser rollt er da drüber. Mag natürlich bei einem Millimeter nicht so wichtig aussehen, aber am Ende kommt da halt schon was zusammen, was da an Rollwiderstand zusammenkommt. Deswegen auch so Geländemotorräder zum Beispiel, haben einfach sehr große Räder. Und so Sportmotorräder sind eher kleiner, wegen auch Gewicht und so natürlich.
Ich fand, dass meine 5er-Rollen einfach geil aussahen. Ich bin sehr traurig, dass ich die nicht mehr habe. Ich hab auch keine Ahnung, wo sie sind.
Die waren einfach weg. Du hast ja super Ausrede, um jetzt 3er-Rolle zu holen. Oder zumindest mal Probe zu fahren. Kannst dir live berichten.
Na mal gucken, ich bring mich jetzt gerade erst mal wieder lauftechnisch erst mal wieder in Shape. Und wenn ich das schaffe, bis zum nächsten Sommer, das durchzuhalten und ich fit bin, wie ein Tonschuhe auf dem Weg zum Mars, dann würde ich das auch mal wieder erwägen. Weil man soll ja nicht immer so dieses Marathon, das ist auch so ein bisschen gefährlich. Gerade umso älter man wird, ist halt immer so dieser, das schaffe ich noch! Ich bin noch nicht so alt! Kein Problem! Dann bist du dann so eine Randnotiz in der Zeitung so. Ah, wieder einer umgekippt. Sorry.
Wieso gibt es da nicht auch den, wie heißen sie doch gleich, die Busse, die hinterherfahren, auch bei den Skates?
Klumpensammler.
Na ja gut, aber was hilft mir, wenn ich da irgendwie meine Herzattacke kriege?
Ach komm, so schlimm wird es ja wohl nicht sein.
Bei mir? Das denken die anderen auch alle. Tja, so läuft das. Ein Skater ist auch noch bei einem Haufen gefahren.
Jetzt am Wochenende?
Ich bin mir gerade nicht so sicher, ob es hier in Berlin war. Ich glaube doch, da war irgendwas.
Was ist denn deine Distanz gerade beim Laufen?
Oh, wenig. Ich muss mich erstmal wieder ranführen.
Oder was ist denn dein Ziel?
Ich will wieder auf 10 kommen und jetzt bin ich bei 5. Aber es lief schon besser letztes Mal. Ich bin dran.
Guckst du auch auf deinen Tempo?
Ich will einen 6-Minuten-Pace auf jeden Fall halten. Ich will sozusagen die 10 Kilometer in einer Stunde. Das ist jetzt nicht außerordentlich schnell, aber das muss ich schon ein bisschen bewegen. Nicht so hoch ansetzen, so könnte das funktionieren. So hatte ich das auch schon mal, so mache ich das wieder. Und dann kann ich immer noch größer wahnsinnig werden und Marathons laufen wollen oder was weiß ich. Aber ich glaube, so Laufmarathon, das mache ich auf gar keinen Fall. Skatermarathon, mal gucken. Aber dann brauche ich auch einen guten Laufbody. Weil während Laufen, also so normales Laufen, hast du recht, ist geil, weil man da einfach so wunderbar allein sein kann. Aber Skaten macht irgendwie mehr Bock mit Leuten zusammen. Also vielleicht bin ich da falsch sozialisiert, weil ich irgendwie, ich habe mal diese Wahnsinns-Tour da gemacht, habe ich gleich schon erzählt. Ich bin ja mal so von Freiburg nach Hamburg gelaufen. In zwei Wochen. Und dann waren wir halt so eine Truppe von irgendwie 15 Wahnsinnigen und sind halt immer schön Kette gefahren und haben dann so einen Windschatten, einer vorne, die alle anderen so hinten dran mit festhalten. Genau. Das ist so irre. Also das hat so gebockt. Weil klar, das hat den Duftwiderstand von einem, aber halt die Power von 15. Und wir sind da wie so eine Maschine irgendwie so durch dieses Land gelaufen. Mit irgendwie teilweise 60 Sachen. Das rockt schon so richtig. Und dann vor allem allein dieser Sound, den du dann irgendwie hast. War immer ganz lustig. In Städten kam dann irgendwie die Polizei und wollte uns irgendwie erst so ein bisschen führen und so. Und dann haben die gesehen, wie wir da abgegangen sind. Dann sind sie uns irgendwie gleich so mit dem Motorrad vorweg und haben angefangen, die Ampeln auf vorzuschalten.
Hat das du glaubst schon mal erzählt?
Spaßige Zeit, ja, ich bestimmt schon mal erzählt. Ich wiederhole mich ja laufend. Aber wie auch immer, das Skatereis an sich ist eine schöne Sache, aber man muss halt auch aufpassen. Ich hab mich schon mal nach einer Pause mir gedacht, ich bin schon der Coolste und das schaffe ich schon. Und dann lag ich da halt, bumm, und dann hat ich erst mal gebrochenes Handgelenk und viel Spaß.
Und immer schön dehnen vorm Sport.
Immer schön dehnen vorm Sport. So ist aber Schluss mit Sport hier. Los Dennis, jetzt reden wir mal wieder über...
Pokémon.
Über Pokémon Go. Dennis spielt übrigens hier die ganze Zeit Pokémon Go.
Zu seiner Verteidigung nicht nur er.
Ach so, du auch?
Er hat mich ja jetzt infiziert, ja ja.
Na das Schöne ist hier, dass wir hier bei dir genau zwischen zwei Pokestops sitzen. Das heißt, ich kann ja alle 5 Minuten 100 Punkte machen. Und in 4 Stunden kriegt man schon irgendwie ein paar Punkte zusammen, 4800. Auf die so perfekt redet man nicht, aber... Nee, da kann man nicht viel zu erzählen.
Ja, ich wollte auch gar nicht dich auf Pokémon Go ansprechen, sondern ich wollte, dass du mal deine Kompressionserfahrung unter das Volk bringst.
Sehr schön. Also, ich bin ja... Können wir gleich beide Thema hintereinander irgendwie. Die hören ja so, kann ich gut zusammenkleben. Also, fangen wir beide mit Z an. Ihr wisst ja schon, was jetzt kommt. Also, was danach kommt. Also, jetzt erstmal Compression. Gibt's einen neuen Kompressionsalgorithmus von dem gleichen Typen.
Also, wir reden von Datenkompression, nicht von Audio oder Video.
Es gibt ja lossy-Kompression, so Audio, also MPEG und AAC. Also, wenn es nicht lossless ist, dann ist das alles lossy. Und dann gibt's natürlich so wie G-Zip und wie heißt das alles hier? B-Zip, LZMA und Deflate nennt man's auch noch und so weiter. Das ist alles lossless-Kompression. Ja, genau, man kriegt exakt das wieder raus, was man braucht. Es ist besonders gut, wenn man Programme komprimiert oder Daten, die einem wichtig sind. Jedenfalls haben wir, glaube ich, vor zwei, drei Jahren schon mal was vorgestellt, LZ4 von so einem Franzosen. Und der war zwar super, super schnell, also schneller als wirklich alles andere, aber hat auch nur so, naja, die Komprimierungsrate war ein bisschen schlechter als G-Zip. Aber die Geschwindigkeit war es ja auch, wenn man nicht viel Zeit hat zum Beispiel, bei bestimmten Sachen ist das ja so, dann war der ganz gut. Aber wenn man halt besser komprimieren wollte, hat man G-Zip oder B-Zip oder LZMA, wie sie alle heißen. Jedenfalls der gleiche Typ hat jetzt irgendwie wieder zwei Jahre lang an seinem Kämmerchen gearbeitet. Der hat auch einen schicken Blogpost, wo man das immer so verfolgen kann. Ich muss mal gucken, ob ich den jetzt schnell finde. Und dort hat er jetzt einen neuen Kompressionsalgorithmus vorgestellt, den hat er genannt Z-Standard. Da geht es nicht wieder darum, möglichst eine hohe Kompressionsrate zu haben. Da gibt es irgendwie ganz andere. Da gibt es halt diesen LZ-MA zum Beispiel. Oder wie heißt der?
Keine Ahnung, BZIP2 war doch da auch noch.
Man könnte sich auch mal einen Namen überlegen, den man sich merken kann.
Die sind alle so basierend auf den gleichen Technologien. Deswegen muss da in letzter Zeit immer ein Z mit rein, weil das irgendwie Lempel-ZIF-Tralala ist und so. Deswegen kann man das nicht ohne Z machen. Und das andere ist dann immer der Huffman Lempel-ZIF. Hast du nicht gesehen? Also wenn man nach Tiefe einsteigt. Jedenfalls, er war nicht hinter der besten Kompressionsrate hinterher, sondern er wollte, deswegen auch der Name Z Standard, er wollte ein relativ durchschnittliches Komprimier-Ratio haben. Aber das halt in sehr, sehr, sehr schnell. Und ich bin der Meinung, er hat das gut geschafft. Und zwar ist sein Komprimierer besser vom Ratio her als Gezip, aber auch schneller. Und wenn das der Fall ist, wenn du sowohl besser als auch, also schneller bist und sowohl auch besser komprimieren kannst, dann ist der andere Komprimierer sozusagen komplett unnötig. Bei dem LZ4 war das so, das war ja so ein Kompromiss, den nimmst du, wenn du es schnell haben willst, wenn du es ein bisschen besser ratio haben willst, hast du halt Gezip oder einen anderen genommen. Oder wenn du halt sehr, sehr hoch komprimieren willst, nimmst du halt LZMA, dafür war der aber scheiße, scheiße, scheiße langsam. Und das lohnt sich nur, wenn du wirklich archivieren willst und wirklich nur einmal komprimierst, aber vielleicht ganz oft dekomprimierst oder halt für Backup oder so. Aber was ja jetzt heute so mehr die Anwendungsfälle sind, und zwar wenn du so eine gesamte Transport-Compression haben willst, das heißt du willst irgendwie was, ich will das von mir zu dir schicken und unsere Leitung ist halt relativ teuer oder schlecht oder langsam. Das heißt, ich will bei mir komprimieren, will das dann rüber schicken und du musst auch noch wieder dekomprimieren. Und da gibt es auch Benchmark, die das schon so messen. Und da wäre so ein LZ-AMA, der komprimiert zwar gut, aber bevor ich das komprimiert habe, in der Zeit hätte ich das auch mit der langsamen Leitung schon längst zu dir rüber geschickt. Deswegen bringt der da nicht so wirklich. Und der ganz schnelle LZ-4, der würde es zwar relativ schnell komprimieren, aber das Ergebnis wäre immer noch zu groß, was auf unserer langsamen Leitung auch wieder zu lange dauern würde. Und genau da kommt dieser Z-Standard irgendwie dazwischen, weil der ist halt relativ gut noch im Komprimieren und dabei auch noch ziemlich schnell. Und das ist meiner Meinung nach, um dann gleich danach zum nächsten Thema zu kommen, auf jeden Fall ein sehr, sehr heißer Kandidat für On-Disc-Compression, wenn man halt ZFS irgendwie seine Blöcke komprimiert. Da gibt es nämlich schon einen Gzip, habe ich auch mal ausprobiert, aber das ist so langsam, das kannst du einfach nicht benutzen, das macht alles so träge. Und dieser Z-Standard würde den einfach mal lock ersetzen. Jetzt hast du hier die schicke Grafik und dann kann man...
Warte mal, das Ding ist von Facebook?
Ja, der Typ ist irgendwie so Anfang des Jahres, hat ihn Facebook wahrscheinlich mehr oder weniger eingekauft oder irgendwie so, da ist er zu Facebook gegangen. Also er hat ohne Facebook angefangen und ist dann zu Facebook gewechselt. Also der macht das jetzt mit deren Hilfe, könnte man sagen. Vielleicht brauchen die das auch irgendwie und dachten sich, wir fördern das mal. Das weiß ich nicht so ganz genau, wie das geht. Das ist auf jeden Fall Open Source und ja... So und dieser Grafik hast du diese in... Die haben unsere Hörer ja später dann auch die Grafik richtig. Kann ich ja nur jetzt drüber erzählen.
Wenn man da drauf rumklickt, dann sieht man halt hier Compression Speed vs. Ratio, das ist hier auf dieser Homepage, also der GitHub Projekt Homepage drauf. Naja, sieht halt irgendwie schneller und bessere Kompression.
Genau, solange also der Punkt, der gesetzte von dem einen Kompremierer höher und weiter links ist als von dem anderen Kompremierer, bist du auf jeden Fall besser und der andere ist einfach komplett unnötig. Das heißt, mit dem Z-Standard, mit dem 1, 2, 3, 4, mit dem vierten Punkt von unten schon, bist du sowohl schneller und hast aber trotzdem auch schon eine höhere Kompressionsrate. Das heißt, der G-Zip ist einfach egal, in welchem Modus man ihn benutzt, ist nicht so gut wie Z-Standard in Modus 4 oder 5. Irgendwie so. Man kann das noch irgendwie ausreizen, indem man ihn noch schneller macht. Dann kann aber sein, dass der G-Zip besser sein könnte. Oder man macht ihn sehr, sehr, sehr schnell und dann ist man vielleicht nicht so gut wie G-Zip, aber reichlich schneller. Also ich finde, das ist mal was Neues. Das steht auch in dem Facebook, da haben wir einen relativ langen Artikel dazu, das ist jetzt nicht diese Seite, aber da gibt es auch, kann ich ja gleich mal raussuchen. Da erklären sie auch, dass G-Zip schon, es gibt es ja seit 20 Jahren und auch schon seit ewig gibt es natürlich welche, die besser komprimieren als G-Zip. Dann gibt es auch welche, die schneller sind, aber es gibt eigentlich fast keine so richtig oder sehr wenig, die sowohl schneller als auch besser sind und der hat das jetzt geschafft und auch nicht nur so ein bisschen, sondern auch gleich ganz ordentlich. Und die meinen auch, dieser Algorithmus ist erst am Anfang. Sie wollen da demnächst noch mehrere Optionen nachlegen und zwar, dass du ihn noch schneller einstellen kannst, bei weniger Ratio natürlich oder dass er noch besser komprimiert und dadurch auch noch ein bisschen langsam wird. Also, dass sie ihn noch dynamischer einsetzen kann, damit er möglichst breites Spektrum abfertigt. Das ist, könnte man sozusagen, das ist jetzt, ja nicht ganz, aber der Opus der Kompressionstechnologie, wie der Opus Codec, der deckt ja auch so diesen riesengroßen Bereich ab, von ganz kleiner Bitrate bis zu ganz hoher Bitrate ist er in allen Sachen eigentlich besser als die Konkurrenz und der schafft das hier noch nicht ganz, weil wie gesagt, die guten wie LZMA, die sind schon noch besser, aber halt scheiß langsam, aber der ist schon sehr, sehr gut. Also dieser Franzose, Jan Collette, der weiß schon, was er tut.
Ja, das wäre natürlich auch cool, wenn man das sozusagen in so ganz SCP und solchen Sachen irgendwie wenn die das ein bisschen automatisch mit drin hätten.
Ja, das müsste eigentlich gehen, weil das ist ja eigentlich so modulemäßig, die SSHs können das ja so aushandeln. Warum auch in SSH, ich weiß nicht seit wann sie Compression drin haben, eigentlich schon immer seit ich mich erinnern kann, warum sie das nicht auch mal gegen was schickeres irgendwie getauscht haben, ist mir nicht so ganz klar. Weil ich hab das, ist das erste was ich mache, wenn wenn ich hier so ein OS aufsetze, ist Compression on für SSH Connections. Weil dann will ich irgendwie meinen, wenn ich einen Top-Aufruf oder da die Logfiles lang scrollen lasse, dann muss das irgendwie flutschen. Und ja, da braucht man sowas. Also auch wirklich schnelles Leitung, das macht nochmal, wenn die CPUs schnell sind und gut komprimieren können, dann geht nochmal ein bisschen Latenz runter. Also ich finde das flutscht einfach besser, wenn ich da was mache.
Ich vergleiche das hier gerade mal. Also er macht Punkt ZST als Extension ran.
Genau.
Jetzt habe ich das gerade mal auf einem MB3 getestet, das war vielleicht ein bisschen unfair.
Ja, würde ich auch sagen, weil das sollte sich nicht komprimieren lassen.
Naja, so ein bisschen schon, und da ist tatsächlich GZ besser. Das könnte man dann mal nehmen, ein Disk Image oder sowas. Das müsste auch ganz gut gehen, oder?
Ja, aber ein Disk Image ist eventuell auch schon komprimiert.
Nimm einfach den Kernel, wenn du ihn noch findest.
Den Kernel? Ja, wo liegt denn der? Nicht mehr in rot, oder?
Den haben sie versteckt irgendwie. Ich hab ihn letztens auch gesucht. Ein bisschen peinlich. Der ist irgendwie nach Private gewandert oder so was. Ich weiß gar nicht mehr genau. Aber in Slash liegt er nicht mehr.
Die Sau. Einfach das Betriebssystem ohne Kernel ausgeliefert.
Nee, ist ein bisschen woanders hin gewandert.
Tja, was ist denn heute noch unkomprimiert?
Die Binary sind unkomprimiert.
Die Binary? Das ist ja mal ein großes Binary.
Wenn die mal noch unkomprimiert sind.
Du findest jetzt echt den Kernel, nicht? Der ist nicht in Private.
Vielleicht ist er da irgendwo. Ich dachte mir, ich guck mal lieber nach irgendeinem absurdgroßen Programm. Und das ist dann mal ein schönes Beispiel.
Wenn wir schon dabei sind, Apple hat auch irgendwas komisches gemacht, wenn man sich Beta-Versionen von Xcode runterlädt, sind die jetzt gepackt mit etwas, was Punkt Xzip heißt. X-I-P.
X-I-P. Die sind ja auch nicht klein, das sind ja immer noch 2-3 GB, die ich da runterlade, oder? Ja. Also das ist immer noch das komplette Xcode, was man da runterlädt, jedes Mal. Jedes Mal, wenn ich mein Xcode update, ist das so groß, als wenn ich mir sonst ein Serial installiert hätte.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das ist, wenn du den über den App-Store updatest. Es kann sein, dass er dann nur Teile davon update. Also du bist der Meinung, das wäre XZ oder irgendwie sowas?
Ja, das ist auch einer von diesen guten Kompromieren. Das ist ja mal so ein Unterschied zwischen dem Kompressionsalgorithmus, der Name hat und dann gibt es ja irgendwie noch wieder diese Tools, diesen Algorithmus benutzen und daraus so ein Archivformat haben, und das Archivformat hat ja auch nochmal wieder so ein Format. Das heißt zum Beispiel dieser L7 oder wie heißt der sonst?
Der L7-ZIP heißt der.
Genau, und LZMA und LZIP und so, das ist ja alles irgendwie ähnlich, aber die nutzen unterschiedliche Archivformate oder irgendwie so. Die hatten sich da mal nicht so richtig geeinigt, da hat es ein bisschen gedauert. Doch, jetzt geht's ja weiter. So ein ganz El Chippo-Kompression, der den immer schnell zusammengehackt hat. Den brauchen wir aber nicht mehr, weil LZ4 einfach mal 1000 Mal besser ist. So und das Gleiche kann man bei ZFS natürlich auch machen und hat jetzt einer gemacht. Und zwar hat jemand Native ZFS-Encryption eingebaut. Also jetzt, was ist heute Mittwoch? Also am Montag und gestern war die Open ZFS-Konferenz in San Francisco. Und da habe ich mir diesen einen Vortrag da mal angehört über Encryption. Da hat der Typ das mal vorgestellt. Also gab es als Stream und diesmal hat es auch einigermaßen funktioniert. Das war früher aber nicht so toll wie unsere Club-Streams. Da haben wir schon eine hohe Latte gelegt. Also das war jetzt so wie ein 50-Minuten-Vortrag. Kann man jetzt nicht alles wiederholen. Aber so grundsätzlich, der Code ist fertig. Also die Pull-Requests sind da. Das ist Native ZFS-Encryption. Heißt nicht, dass sozusagen die Files entcryptet werden, die du dahin speichern willst und ZFS darunter weiß nichts. Sondern das File ist entcryptet. Das ist nicht der Fall. Und das ist auch nicht der Fall, dass einfach die Blöcke, die ZFS nutzt, unten drunter verschlüsselt werden. So wie das Freebies D schon macht mit diesem Gehli. Du machst so einen Kryptocontainer und dann sagst du dem ZFS jetzt, hier, da drauf speicherst du dich. Also dass es das nicht mitkriegt. Sondern das Native heißt, dass das ZFS das komplett selbst macht. Das hat aber auch Nachteile und Vorteile. Also du kannst halt die Pool-Struktur noch sehen. Du kannst die Datasets noch sehen, also welche Filesystems da sind. Aber du kannst halt den Inhalt nicht mehr sehen. Das heißt, du könntest einen riesen Pool haben, der auch schon bootet, weil dein Boot-Filesystem ist halt nicht verschlüsselt, weil du willst ja davon booten. Und wenn es dann aber oben ist, loggst du dich ein, checkst alles klar, ist ja alles okay hier noch, hat keiner an meinen Daten rumgefuscht. Und dann mountest du halt den verschlüsselten Pool mit deinem Key und dann legt deine Kiste los. Das kann man dann alles machen. Und dadurch, dass das so native ist mit dem Encryption, gibt es da auch so Sachen, dass zum Beispiel Scrup, womit man sein ZFS checkt, das kann dann auch funktionieren, obwohl du das gar nicht entschlüsseln kannst. Sondern der kann die Daten ja so checken anhand der Checksum. Das muss er dir nicht entschlüsseln. Das heißt, er checkt das einfach so durch. Und bei dem Resilver wohl genauso. Also der kann dann merken, dass dieser eine Block kaputt ist, obwohl er verschlüsselt ist, holt sich dann von der zweiten Platte aus dem Mirror, holt sich den anderen verschlüsselten Block, und schiebt den da drüber und muss das nicht mal dekrypten dafür, sondern macht das einfach so. Und ja, ich finde das voll gut. Das ist, was die bei Oracle schon irgendwie ganz früh hatten. Aber dann haben sie ja kurz vorher irgendwie den Open Source-Stöpsel zugedrückt und dann konnte das nicht mehr mitgeforkt werden. Und das haben die jetzt sozusagen nachgereicht.
Hast du da einen Link für?
Da musst du mal auf die Open-ZFS-Seite gehen und da ist dann Werbung für diese Konferenz, die da gestern und vorgestern war. Und da wiederum ist der Talk. Ich weiß nicht, ob die Videos jetzt schon veröffentlicht sind. Ich habe das live geguckt und die sind halt eben nicht so schnell wie der Club mit Videos veröffentlicht und so. Es kann sein, dass das ein bisschen dauert. Aber der hat das alles sehr gut erklärt, wie sie das auch mit dem Key-Management machen und wie sie dafür sorgen, dass die Angriffe da nicht so richtig funktionieren, weil man ja, wenn man als Mensch so schwache Passwörter eingibt, dass es trotzdem auch mit Brute Force, du nicht einfach irgendwie diesen Key denn da durchrechnen kannst und so. Also ich hatte das Gefühl, der Typ hat wirklich Ahnung von was er da redet. Und das hat mir sehr, sehr, also es hat mich, also mich hat das voll überzeugt. Was ich ein bisschen schade finde, ist, dass das ist für Linux irgendwie gebaut. Das gibt's schon ein Pull-Request für, für OS X, OS X. Und der, ja Mac OS, schuldigung, genau, und dieser Jörg Lundmann oder weißt der auch diesen ZFS-Power für Mac OS macht, der hat auch da wohl viel mitgeholfen bei diesem Encryption. Deswegen kann man davon ausgehen, dass es demnächst gibt's dann ZFS auf dem Mac, dann mit Native Encryption. Und dann noch für dieses Illum OS gibt's das auch. Nur für Freebase, die halt irgendwie nicht, weil irgendwie habe ich da was gelesen von die bei Freebase, die haben ja ihr eigenes Krypto-Framework und überhaupt, und sie könnten das nicht integrieren oder wollen nicht oder irgendwie so ein Yada, Yada, Yada. Und das ist natürlich ein bisschen schade, weil genau da hätte ich es halt gerne gehabt. Aber vielleicht, nachdem der jetzt diesen Talk gegeben hat, vielleicht lassen sich ja die Freebase-Jungs auch überzeugen, dass der Typ da schon weiß, was er tut und dass das eine tolle Sache ist. Eine Sache, die noch auch sehr interessant war, da macht das ja der Arbeit bei so einer Firma, die das halt professionell brauchen, dieses Encryption-Feature. Und zwar wollen sie, dass ihre Kunden ZFS benutzen können und die Backups verschlüsselt zu denen in die Cloud schicken, aber halt verschlüsselt, er meint, damit sie eben nicht die Möglichkeit haben, das zu decrypten und auch nicht die Liability haben, das decrypten zu können, sondern dass nur der Kunde das kann. Also das heißt, du schickst dein verschlüsseltes Backup zu denen hin und holst es dir von da wieder, aber die Firma kann einfach genau nichts damit anfangen oder die, denen halt die Cloud da gehört, weil es alles einfach gekryptet ist und das hört sich auch sehr, sehr gut an.
Aber der Terrorismus, aber die Terroristen.
Ja, die können das dann halt auch nutzen, ne? Aber die Terroristen, die fahren auch Auto und so weiter. Telefonieren und nutzen Google. Ich glaub, die nutzen ganz schön viel Google, hab ich gehört.
Schlimm.
Sollte man verbieten. Sog dieses Internet, ist eigentlich nur voll von Kriminellen. Alles böse ZFS-Nutzer, Kryptomacher.
Also bei allen Talks steht unter Video und Slice noch TBA to be announced.
Dann kommt wahrscheinlich noch das nächste, was sie da hatten. Das interessiert mich auch. Hab ich aber dann natürlich saß an meinem Rechner, dachte alles klar, gleich kommt der Vortrag und dann klinke ich mich ein. Dann wurde ich natürlich wieder abgelenkt, wie das immer so ist. Dann hab ich ihn voll verpasst. Und zwar ist da ein Typ, der irgendwie das Scrubbing, wenn man sein ZFS mal durchchecken will, irgendwie optimiert hat. In einer sehr schlauen Art und Weise. Und das wollte ich mir eigentlich angucken, aber das habe ich verschnarcht.
Mach doch mal einen Link direkt auf diese Talks, die du jetzt erwähnt hast.
Ja, Open ZFS oder kann das nicht der Roddy machen? Du bist doch schon gerade auf der Seite, oder?
Ja, da war zum Summit da was, aber es war jetzt noch kein... Ich weiß nicht, ob die Talks einzeln verlinkt sind. Dann wäre das ja schon mal ganz hilfreich.
Also von dieser Seite aus sind die Talks einzeln verlinkt. Aber es sind auch nur ein Dutzend.
Ja, es ist ja nur eine ganz kleine Konferenz. Sie läuft über einen Tag und am zweiten Tag. Also gestern war es schon nur so Hackathon, wo die halt so ein bisschen da rumhacken.
Also es sind auch nur fünf Talks verlinkt. Und dazu steht dann immer nur so zwei Absätze lang was. Also solange jetzt keine Videos oder Slides kommen, ist das jetzt nur von begrenzter Interessanz.
Ja, ich würde ihnen einfach die Hauptseite für das Open ZFS geben und sonst nicht die Leute da durchklicken. Das macht ja mehr Sinn.
Ja, ich hab's auch gefunden.
Hackathon hätten sie ja gestern gleich mal diesen Z-Standard einbauen können. Das kann ja nicht so schwer sein, weil das Gezip ist ja schon da. Das heißt, du musst ja nur, jeder muss ja nur die, ja doch, das geht relativ einfach. Ich hab schon zweimal mit zwei Kumpels, jeweils zwei verschiedenen, hab ich einmal, was haben wir eingebaut? Snappy von Google hatten wir mal eingebaut als Komprimierer und ich glaub mit dem Erdgeist aus dem Club hab ich irgendwann mal, ich glaub LZO war's, haben wir eingebaut. Zusätzlich. Wurden ja aber beide nicht genommen, weil dann kam ja LZ4 und dann war das alles nicht mehr so top notch, was wir da benutzt hatten, aber so grundsätzlich geht das relativ easy. Also schreibst ja keinen neuen Code, du musst ja nur den, der für andere Komprimierer da ist, musst ja nur nehmen und auch so benutzen und dich einhängen in die Liste der Komprimierer. Also ist ja schon alles modular.
So wollen wir nochmal über Sierra reden.
Sierra Leone?
Wenn es da was zu sagen kippt, zu?
Das hat sich so wenig geändert von irgendwie sichtbaren Geschichten.
Das sind ja nicht die sichtbaren, sind die unsichtbaren.
Also Siri nutzt das, ich kann das nicht benutzen. Ich hab das zu Hause einmal probiert, weil ich hab außerdem draufgeklickt, dachte ich, okay, fragst mal nach der Uhrzeit oder irgendein Scheiß und das ging schon gleich so schief und dann hatte ich schon gleich wieder die Schnauze voll. Also nee, das geht gar nicht.
Aber das ist auch so neunmal klug irgendwie.
Ich benutze es immer nur auf der Apple TV und manchmal ist es wirklich zum Haare raufensitzen.
Ich hab Siri gefragt, was das Logo vom ersten FC Union Berlin ist. Und dann kam so ein ganz spitzes Bild. Na ja, sie hat das dahingeschrieben, das was ich gesagt habe, aber...
Okay, ist ja schonmal was.
Ja, gut, hat aber dann nicht viel geholfen und hat sie mir dann irgendwie die Liga der zweiten, also die aktuelle Tabelle der zweiten Bundesliga so gemacht.
Immerhin?
Hatt ich jetzt nicht nach gefragt, aber ist ja vielleicht mal, das war wahrscheinlich das einzige, was sie...
Sie hat Logo mit Liga verwechselt.
Das kann gut sein.
Hast du da genuschelt?
Aber was da ganz pfiffig war, war, ja, aber Union hätte ja die letzten vier Spiele gewonnen, sieht ja ganz gut aus. Das fand ich dann schon wieder ganz knuffig. Und stimmt auch.
Welcher Platz sind die jetzt?
Zweiter.
Ui, zweiter.
Da hat Pauli geputzt.
War letztes Spiel, ne?
War geil. Montag.
Wo war es dann?
Ja, war lecker.
Hier, oder?
Ja, alte Försterei.
Wie viel gewonnen?
2-0. Jetzt sind wir auch schon mit Fußball eingestiegen.
Ja, das ist, also, so eine Sache finde ich witzig so, wenn die versucht, so ein bisschen personal zu werden, weil du scheinst sie ja für FC Union zu interessieren, also beantwortet sie oder, ja, also sie hat ja Smalltalk gemacht. Sie hat dir ja was erzählt, was du nicht gefragt hast. Nein, das würde ich ja schon ein bisschen unter Smalltalk einbuchen.
Also diesen Bezug Liga-Logo habe ich jetzt tatsächlich so nicht gezogen, aber es hat schon auch Logo erkannt.
Also sobald es ja da stand.
Jaja, weil es ja da steht, so, ne. Von daher, sobald der Bundeslogo, keine Ahnung, was die von mir hält. Naja, trotzdem, wir haben ja über Sierra noch nicht geredet und es gibt ja schon noch so ein paar kleine Änderungen, ne.
Meine kleinste Lieblingsänderung. Und ich weiß nicht, ob wir das schon letztes Mal hatten.
Letztes Mal haben wir über Networking gesprochen, diese IPv6-Deschichte.
Ach so, ich mein was ganz anderes. Und zwar jetzt oben hier in den Menüs da, wie heißen die eigentlich, diese kleinen oben rechts? Jedenfalls, da gibt es doch den für diesen kleinen Lautsprecher, wo man früher nur die Lautstärke einrichten konnte, ne. Und der hat jetzt per Default, kann man jetzt auch das Output Device einstellen, was früher nur ging, wenn man die Alt-Taste gedrückt hat. Inzwischen muss man die Alt-Taste zwar noch drücken, wenn man auch das Input Device regeln will, oder einstellen will, aber inzwischen kann man jetzt mit einem ganz normalen Klick auswählen, über was man jetzt eigentlich irgendwie seinen Sound gerne hören würde. Und das finde ich schon, das ist seit Jahren fällig. Weil ich hab diesen Button fast nie für Lautstärke benutzt, aber immer mit Alt, um das Device auszuwählen.
Und der Regler ist jetzt horizontal und nicht mehr vertikal, das ich auch sehr schön fand.
Daran muss man sich glaube ich erstmal gewöhnen.
Nö, muss ich nicht.
Das haben sie schon nach 15 Jahren irgendwie begriffen, dass man vielleicht mal mehr als einen Lautsprecher an seinem Scheißsystem dran hat. Ja, jetzt wo sie selber Bluetooth-Kopfhörer machen, ist es auf einmal wichtig, schnell hin und her zu schalten. Soll ja ganz geil sein, ne? Diese komischen AirPods. Ob wir ehrlich gesagt nicht verstehen, wie man... Na okay, das ist jetzt nicht das Thema. Lass uns erstmal bei Sierra bleiben.
Was ich noch festgestellt habe, ist, weil ich bin ja so der Krypto-Fan, dass auf dem iPhone mache ich das ja schon eine Weile, aber auf dem Mac OS, danke, gegen das immer irgendwie nicht so richtig. Und das tut jetzt auch einfach irgendwie hier... Gebt da einfach meine Gegenstelle ein, sag irgendwie, was hier die ID von mir ist und die ID von der Gegenstelle ist, dann fragt er mich noch nach dem ShareSecret, weil ich mach das gerade noch mit ShareSecret.
Warte mal, du redest jetzt von VPNs.
VPNs, so nennt man die heutzutage.
Wie nannte man sie denn früher?
Gar nicht.
Ist IPsec denn immer VPN? IPsec ist doch nur ein Betriebsmodus.
VPN ist für mich so ein Wort wie Firewall, das kann man so und so lösen, ich weiß nicht genau. Also ich...
Passt auf, sonst muss Clemens wieder Tischkanten kaputt machen.
Das wird er jetzt wahrscheinlich eh schon, der nagt hier.
Jedenfalls tut das jetzt sehr gut. Ich kann hier klicken und sofort ist das oben und eine IPv6-Adresse kommt dann auch, falls du jetzt keine hättest, hätte ich dann eine IPv6... Nee, aber durch meinen VPN kommt dann eine IPv6 zu mir auch. Und im Café sitzt du nur mit IPv4 und ich denke, IPv6 ist eigentlich viel cooler, zack, VPN angemacht. Und dann habe ich eine VPN mit IPv4 und IPv6-Adresse. Genau.
Wohin dann?
Zu meinem Endpunkt.
Ja, aber was?
Strongsworn. Da hat mich letztens einer angetwittert, er hätte das nicht hinbekommen, mit FreeBSD und Strongsworn. Bei mir tut das. Er muss nochmal Doku lesen. Ich weiß, dass alle von mir wollen, dass ich das noch mal veröffentliche, aber ich habe ja keinen Blog überhaupt. Ich mach das demnächst nochmal mit einem Kumpel aus dem Klub fertig, dass es auch schick Zerts benutzt und keine Scherz-Secrets. Dass es jetzt alles auch noch top und schmuck aussieht, weil es jetzt nur noch so geht, aber es ist alles noch nicht so schick.
Wenn du so wollen, sind Slack einfach Support machen. Wie beständig er hier an seinem Podcast kaputt gedreht ist.
Ja, aber irgendwie tun die gerade nicht mehr. Ich glaube, ich habe die Pokestops kaputt gedreht. Diese App, das geht auch gar nicht. So ein Neustart, das ist schon unglaublich.
Wenn er nicht mehr will, dann musst du ihn einfach killen.
Was hast du hier noch aufgeschrieben? Hat sich jetzt noch was mit SSH geändert?
Ja, und zwar muss man das kurz mal erklären, was das ist. Also man kann ja mit SSH auf einen anderen Rechner springen, um sich da schnellmäßig irgendwie auszutoben. Aber wenn man ja ein bisschen Profi ist, und ich hoffe, das sind wir alle, dann macht man das natürlich nicht per Passwort, sondern man hinterlegt auf dem anderen Rechner den lokalen Key, den man sich erzeugt hat. Also den Public Key? Den Public Teil davon, genau, den privaten, hält man. Und dann lockt man sich ein. Das heißt, keiner kann irgendwie das Passwort von der Tastatur ablesen, wenn man sich woanders einlockt. Und man kann sogar dieses Key-File auch ohne Passwort machen. Das heißt, du lockst dich einfach ein, du musst gar kein Passwort eingeben, oder du kannst da ein Passwort drauflegen, aber das ist halt für den Key. Und der, der dein Passwort sieht, was du da tippst, der hat halt den Key nicht, kann sich auf der anderen Seite also immer noch nicht einloggen. Und jeder, der Brute Force auf dein Rechner macht und versucht, sich einzuloggen, hat keine Chance, weil Key Only, das geht einfach nicht. Deswegen will man eigentlich immer mit Keys arbeiten. So, jetzt gibt es aber noch den Fall, dass man auf Rechner, also der eigene Rechner ist jetzt mal A, man hüpft auf Rechner B, man will aber eigentlich auf einen Rechner C drauf, der nur von Rechner B erreichbar ist. Wenn nicht, müsst ihr zurückspielen, euch das nochmal anhören. So, wenn...
Ja, so ein Middleman, der halt nur einen Zugang hat.
Genau, so ein Jump-Horse, wie auch immer man das nennt. Und wenn aber Rechner C auch nur mit Key ist, dann will man eventuell sein Key ja nicht auf Rechner B hinterlegen. Deswegen gibt es sowas wie Agent Forwarding. Das heißt, du sagst bei SSH minus Groß A, das heißt, der eigene Key wird zunächst mitübertragen in diesen Agent und wenn du von Rechner B dann auf Rechner C springst, dann wird der Key aus dem Agent geholt. Das ist jetzt mal so grob umschrieben. Ihr könnt jetzt gerne Tischkanten beißen, ist mir egal. Aber so geht das. Aber seit Sierra geht das nicht mehr, weil die Keys, die man hat, nicht mehr default irgendwie in diesem Agent drin sind. Und deswegen muss man die jetzt immer von Hand reinmachen. Und dann hab ich mal eine Weile gegoogelt, ob das ein Sierra-Problem ist oder was da irgendwie los ist. Und dann hat einer ganz schlau geschrieben, naja, die bei Sierra, die haben halt von Open SSH 6 auf Open SSH 7 gewechselt. Und dort gibt's jetzt eine neue Option, die heißt Add Keys to Agent. Und die ist anscheinend per Default auf No oder irgendwie so. Und deswegen sind die Keys nicht mehr drin, werden nicht mit übertragen und deswegen kannst du das mit dem Jumping irgendwie nicht so gut machen. Du müsstest vorher immer manuell SSH minus Add, glaube ich, machen und dein Key irgendwie zu dem Agent dazu addieren. Ist das nicht SSH Add? Doch, SSH Add, genau. Aber eigentlich muss man nur diese Option auf Yes setzen und dann hat sich das Problem erledigt und dann ist gut.
Aber ich hab doch da schon, also ich habe in meinen SSH-Config immer das Setting Forward, Agent, Yes. Das reicht jetzt nicht mehr?
Na, dann mach das doch mal mit dem Jumping, ob das immer noch so funktioniert. Bei mir tat das nicht mehr. Ja, außer du addierst vorher dein Key zu dem Agent.
Ja, ich dachte die Option reicht da vollkommen aus.
Na, ich weiß nicht, ob ich da überhaupt irgendwelche speziellen Optionen hatte für, bin mir nicht so sicher. Ich muss mir das demnächst halt sowieso dann alles nochmal neu angucken, weil ich glaube, man kann auch sein Key verschlüsseln und den aber dann auch in der Keychain ablegen, das geht nämlich, weil das ist irgendwie kombiniert hier irgendwie.
Nee, du kannst das, du kannst die Passphrase von dem Key kannst du in der Keychain ablegen.
Ja genau, das meine ich. Also ja, nicht den Key selbst, sondern die Passphrase.
Das geht aber schon ewig.
Ja, das muss ich mir halt nochmal genau angucken, dass das auch alles wieder genau so ist, weil ich glaube, ich hab mir diesmal ein Key erstellt, weil ich hab letztens mal erneuert, weil man soll jetzt auf RSA umstellen oder eigentlich diese Elliptic Curve und so.
Guck dir die GitHub-Anleitung an, da steht als letzter Punkt, wie man das macht, mit dem SSH Agent irgendwie auch.
Welches GitHub? Ach so, das, dass man da...
Du kannst ja bei GitHub selber auch einen Key hinterlegen und da gibt es eine Anleitung, wie du das machst. Und der letzte Schritt von dieser Anleitung, der erklärt quasi, wie du den Key...
Ja, das sollte man tun, dass der da nicht so einfach...
Beziehungsweise du gibst eigentlich nur dem Agent bekannt, dass es jetzt diesen neuen Key gibt und dann fragt er das nächste Mal nach dem Passwort und ob er in den Keychain ablegen soll oder nicht.
Ja, das heißt, dass Apple dann auch dieses SSH-Ad oder den Agent Keychain kompatibel gemacht hat.
Ja, aber wie gesagt, schon seit Ewigkeiten.
Naja, weil die benutzen das ja auch dann, ne? Ja, ich hab das auch noch nicht probiert. Wie gesagt, wenn man den Key zu dem Agent addiert mit diesem SSH-Ad, das hält ja auch so lange, bis man halt den nächsten Reboot von seinem Rechner macht. Das ist mir natürlich dann besonders häufig aufgefallen, als jetzt im Sommer irgendwie jede Woche ich einmal für das neue Beta-Sierra irgendwie booten musste. Das heißt, ich musste jede Woche immer wieder feststellen, das ist scheiße, ich muss ja diese Keys addieren. Und irgendwann geht es einem ja dann doch auf den Sack und dann googelt halt manchmal, was das Problem ist.
Und sie haben, glaube ich, die DSR-Keys jetzt deprecated, ne? Die funktionieren nicht mehr so richtig.
Das kann sein, da war irgendwas. Deswegen hab ich mir auch im Sommer schon irgendwann im Mai oder so halt RSA-Key erzeugt. Aber eigentlich, glaube ich, soll man Elliptic Curve machen. Was mich ja wundert ist, oder was ich mich frage ist, weil man ja nie genau weiß ist, RSA jetzt gerade hat das einer kaputt gemacht oder hat das Elliptic Curve einer kaputt gemacht oder hat das DSR einer kaputt gemacht oder das soll ja jetzt angeblich kaputt sein. Warum man die alle nicht in Kombination benutzt und nicht nur einen davon, sondern so ein Key, der aus allen dreien irgendwie besteht, weil dann müssen sie halt alles drei kaputt machen. Weil wenn mir einer sagt, ja, hier benutzt man Elliptic Curve, dann weiß ich ja nicht, wer so dahinter steckt. Vielleicht sagt das ja der, der weiß, dass das auch schon gehackt ist oder dass sie wissen, wie man es umgehen kann und will mich halt dann genau da in diese Richtung schieben. Das ist jetzt ein bisschen Verschwörungstheoriemäthig, aber ich meine, wenn man einfach drei Key-Verfahren kombinieren würde, dann hätte der Attacker schon seine Schwierigkeiten, weil man müsste alle drei kaputt machen.
Also soweit ich weiß, gibt es ja auch irgendwie 1001 Elliptic-Curves, die man verwenden kann, die alle unterschiedlich gut sind.
Aber wenn das Konzept komplett kaputt ist, weiß ich halt eben nicht. Versteht ja auch so eine Mathematiker, versteht das ja keiner.
Elliptic-Curve ist ja im Prinzip Diffie-Hellman, nur dass du irgendwie anders wegmachst.
Im Prinzip verstanden hast du das aber auch nicht.
Es gab irgendwo mal einen Talk, wo ich immerhin in die Nähe gekommen bin, zu verstehen, worum es gehen könnte.
Ich habe hier irgendwo noch, glaube ich, einen Artikel, den ich mal gelesen habe dazu.
Zumindest habe ich verstanden, worum es Elliptic-Curve heißt, was ja schon mal was ist.
Und Timmy, bist du immer noch am rumjumpen mit SSH?
Ja, ich muss hier gerade noch mal irgendwie meine Fritzbox neu starten. Meine Fritzbox nochmal hier. Weil ich habe gerade zu wenig Hosen draus, mit denen ich das rumtesten kann.
Ich kann ja mal was in eigener Sache sagen. Und zwar wollte ich das eigentlich schon zum letzten Mal, aber da bin ich ja dann ausgefallen.
Du bist Star-Podcaster.
Nee, das nicht. Also das auch. Aber darüber wollte ich jetzt nicht reden. Ich habe doch da so eine Mac-App im Mac-App-Store seit Unzeiten, also sprich, seit er eröffnet wurde. Und die App ist auch noch älter. Und da habe ich jetzt den Stöpsel gezogen und die auf Free gesetzt, weil ich da jetzt keine Lust mehr zu habe, die weiter zu maintainen.
Die schmeißen den auch demnächst eher raus, wenn du dich nicht kümmerst, oder?
Das Problem ist, dass ich die irgendwann mal auf Garbage Collection umgestellt habe. Und das Sierra funktioniert Garbage Collection nicht mehr. Das haben sie irgendwie zu... Was war das davor? Diese Berge nicht merken. El Capitan. Zu El Capitan hatten sie schon angekündigt, okay, das ist jetzt das letzte Release, was noch Garbage Collection schon haben wird. Und das Release danach dann nicht mehr. Das stand in den Beta-Release-Notes von Capitan schon drin. Und da dachte ich mir, jetzt müsstest du eigentlich mal, müsstest du, habe ich aber nie gemacht. Und jetzt habe ich einfach gesagt, ja, okay. Läuft halt jetzt nicht mehr und das Sierra ist gut.
Da hat es sich wieder voll gelohnt, dass ich diese neuen Sachen immer aussitze. Weil dieses Garbage Collection hat mir irgendwie nie gefallen. Ich dachte, ich setze das aus und es hat tatsächlich funktioniert. Ich bin gleich zu arg rüber gesprungen und es hat damit mit diesem Scheiß nichts zu tun.
Ich glaube, als ich Garbage Collection angefangen hatte, gab es arg noch nicht.
Ja, aber da gab es ja noch, dass man es halt manuell macht.
Ja, genau. Aber das war halt auch ein Pain.
Ja, aber ich habe das seit 2002 manuell gemacht. Das hatte ich schon einigermaßen im Griff, würde ich mal behaupten.
Naja, es hatte sich für diese App halt auch so ein Perfect Storm zusammen entwickelt. Das Erste ist, dass ich die App hatte, die ich im App Store hatte, als er aufgemacht wurde, und dann gab es im App Store noch kein Sandboxing. Und dann hätte ich die App auf Sandboxing umbauen müssen, was relativ schwierig ist, wenn man eine App schreibt, die eigentlich auf die ganze Festplatte zugreifen möchte. Und dann, naja, das hatte ich schon so halbwegs hingekriegt, und dann kam halt OpenSSL.
Was ist denn deine App überhaupt?
Die vierte, doppelte, duplizierte Dateien.
Duplicate Finder. Du brauchst dafür OpenSSL?
Ja, für die nicht App Store Version, bzw. auch für die App Store Version, für die Lizenz-Krypto. Genau, weil die sollte man ja mal Geld bezahlen. Haben ja auch ein paar Leute gemacht. Und es ist mir bis heute nicht gelungen, das irgendwie anders zu machen als mit OpenSSL. Ich hab dann noch versucht, irgendwie LibreSSL zu kompilieren und zu verwenden, aber das ist mir irgendwie auch nicht geglückt. Du bist doch jetzt dabei, oder?
Er benutzt das doch, wenn du guckst, dass der OpenSSL steht da, gebaut ist mit LibreSSL.
Das mag sein, aber du kriegst keine Hedder-Files dafür. Also das wird einfach nicht unterstützt. Du kannst das nicht mehr als... Vorher war das halt einfach, du hast halt gesagt, hier, include das und dann hattest du den Kram und musstest sonst nichts machen irgendwie. Also vielleicht noch irgendwie die richtige Library linken. Und naja, dann hab ich irgendwann gesagt, jetzt schmeiß den Scheiß hin und gut ist. Jetzt will ich irgendwann noch zumindest diesen ganzen Krypto-Krempel ausbauen und noch ein paar andere Sachen irgendwie feilen und dann kommt's auf GitHub und alles gut. So bis Ende des Jahres hab ich mir vorgenommen, mal sehen, ob das klappt. Ja, da geht's dahin. Eine App, die Prä-App Store ist. Ja, auf der Download-Seite steht noch. Ja, und die und die Version läuft noch unter 10.2 und die und die Version läuft noch unter 10.3 und die und die Version läuft noch unter 10.4. Hat aber kein 32-Bit mehr, weißt du so. Ja, du kannst sogar noch eine Power-PC-kompatible Version runterladen. Das ist ja. Aber jetzt halt nicht mehr. Nee, naja, gut, sagen wir mal so. Auf ARK hatte ich sie schon umgestellt. Na ja, ich versuchte irgendwie mit Common-Kropter zu machen, aber das hat irgendwie nicht funktioniert. Und ach, das ist alles ein... Weil er nicht schnell genug hinterher ist, dann hängt ein Apple gnadenlos ab.
Was ja jetzt auch noch so eine Neuigkeit ist, das bezieht sich aber jetzt auf iOS 10. Bezieht sich ja auf iOS 10. Da gibt es ja jetzt dieses neue Call-Kit bei iOS 10. Also, dass Apps sich quasi in das System so einklinken können, als wären sie eine Telefon-App sozusagen.
Na ja gut, da haben wir ja drüber geredet, dass es kommen soll, aber jetzt sind halt auch die Apps draußen.
Jetzt haben sie es tatsächlich ernst gemacht.
Ja, Skype kam gerade erst ein Update durch, heute oder so. Die machen das jetzt auch.
Skype macht es jetzt auch? Ah, okay, die haben noch gefehlt. Für mich natürlich sehr schön, dass es das jetzt auch mit GroundWire gibt, was so ein ganz korrekter SIP-Kline des St. Clemens hier mal aufgebracht hat, der hervorragend auch so als Studio-Link-Endpoint funktioniert. Einziges Problem ist, dieses Call-Kit, also ich meine, jetzt klingelt zwar das Telefon und man kriegt jetzt sozusagen die Aufmerksamkeit am Telefon. So weit, so gut, nur bin ich ja jetzt auch schon wieder ein paar Jahre weiter und benutze ja mein Telefon immer silent. Das heißt, ich kriege das jetzt trotzdem nicht mit, weil meine Erwartungshaltung war ja, dass wenn jetzt mein Telefon klingelt, dass auch noch meine Uhr klingelt. Aber das tun sie natürlich nicht. Das heißt, die Uhr klingelt nur, wenn du einen normalen Telefonanruf kriegst und wenn du jetzt halt irgendwie so einen Internetanruf kriegst, der jetzt eigentlich so ein bisschen als wichtiger einsortiert werden sollte, dann stehst du halt immer noch blöd da. Also ich mein, schon besser als vorher, aber das fand ich dann doch ein bisschen enttäuschend.
Aber das hatst du in der letzten Sendung schon rumgeheult, oder?
Aber nicht mit der Apple Watch. Nee, da hab ich ja jetzt erst rausgefunden.
Aber da hast du schon gehört.
Gerade erst gehört.
Nicht dein Ernst. Okay, dann nehm ich das jetzt zurück, wir nehmen das raus.
Wir schneiden das weg.
Du solltest selber mal meine Sendung hören.
Ich hab im Slack mal so ein schönes Bild zum Thema Samsung und abbrennende Telefone gepostet. Ja, relativ alt, aber ich fand's trotzdem sehr nett.
Ja, alt.
Sind die alle Themen schon abgearbeitet, oder wie?
Ja, heut war ja nix, hab ich ja gesagt. Heute hatten wir auch keine Kraft, neue Themen zu schaffen. Wir können uns natürlich noch über die Berliner Wahl unterhalten.
Und was genau willst du da sagen? Dass die Piraten es gerade mal so vor die Tierschutzpartei geschafft haben in Prozenten?
Nein, dass in Friedrichshain die Partei irgendwie in einem BVV mit eingezogen ist.
Nein, ich will nicht wirklich über die Wahl reden, weil ich finde, da gibt's nicht sehr viel zu sagen.
Ich fand die auch nicht überraschend.
Nee, ich fand die auch nicht überraschend. Überraschend fand ich nur so die finale Inszenierung des Piratenabgangs, das war dann doch ein bisschen over the top.
Der Killer-Pirat? Oder wie war die Tat, die Schlagzeile?
Nee, doch, das war ganz schön schlecht.
Das war richtig schlecht, ja.
Ja, damit ist das Ding jetzt auch wirklich durch. Du bist jetzt irgendwie Podcaster geworden, habe ich gehört, habe ich gelesen im Internet.
Ja, so ein Werbe-Posting für die Firma. Ich dachte, naja, dann erzählst du mal was. Ja, im Prinzip ist es so, dass es da, naja, wie jede größere Firma, gibt es da eine Marketing-Abteilung und die wollen irgendwelche News haben auf ihrem Blog und haben halt gefragt, wer könnte denn mal was zu seinem Hobby erzählen? Und ein Kollege hat was zur Fitness erzählt und einer hat was zum Hobbyschreinern erzählt und ich hab halt was zum Podcasting erzählt und hab mir dazu das Equipment von dem Herrn Prittlauf ausgeliehen und das in die Kamera gehalten. Und das wurde auch sehr schön abgelichtet, muss ich sagen. Das stimmt. Ich weiß nicht, wie viel Geld die Fotografin gekriegt hat, aber sie hat ihren Job auf jeden Fall gut gemacht.
Ja genau, das ist nämlich mein Mobil-Set. So schön hab ich das selber noch nicht dokumentiert bekommen.
Bitte, also von mir aus kannst du die Fotos verwenden. Ich weiß allerdings nicht, ob da...
Die Fotos? Na ja, Fotos kann ich auch noch selber machen, aber ich glaube, ich habe das jetzt noch nicht so sehr gepostet. Das war halt irgendwie...
Also ich habe versucht, möglichst viele sinnvolle Links unterzubringen zu auch anderen interessanten Podcasting-Projekten. Ja, sehr gelungen. Dachte ich mir, wenn schon Werbung, dann bitte auch in die andere Richtung.
Ich frage mich immer nur, wer liest das?
Das weiß ich nicht, aber mich haben ein halbes Dutzend Kollegen darauf angesprochen, fanden das interessant.
Die Frage ist, ob du das außerhalb von Ebay irgendjemand liest.
Das kann ich dir nicht sagen.
Das wäre doch eigentlich auch mal ganz cool.
Jetzt, wo wir Werbung für die Werbung gemacht haben, liest sie vielleicht jemand.
Ein unglaublicher Spike in unserem Kleinanzeigen-Blog. Der Roddy, der muss ja wirklich...
Wir sollten öfter über Roddy sprechen, wenn die sich jetzt denken.
Genau, zentral für die Zukunftsperspektiven von Ebay machen bringen. Ohne Roddy läuft da nichts. So Leute.
Da hab ich ja hier über diesen Stimmgewaltchor berichtet, über den ich, indem ich da mal eine Weile lang mitgesungen hab. Und da meinte der eine so, oha, das haben wir direkt als Spike gemerkt. Also das war nicht zu übersehen. Haben doch relativ viele Leute dann geklickt.
So, hat noch jemand ein Thema? Oder wollen wir heute mal früh Schluss machen? Wir sind irgendwie themlos. Na, wenn uns nichts einfällt, fällt uns nichts ein.
Halb elf ist schon fast so ein bisschen deprimierend.
So ein Chat wurde schon der Finger in die Wunde gelegt.
Welche denn?
Reicht nicht, ne?
Ich mein, das ist doch wirklich ein Laden, der...
Aber mal ganz ehrlich, sie haben die Hardware-Sparte eingespart. Ich meine, Hardware war ja immer das größte Argument, diese Tastatur, die Blackberry hatte. War eigentlich, naja gut, und ihre E-Mail-Anbindung über... Jaja, ihre Mailserver. Mailserver und die Hardware-Tastatur.
Die Hardware-Tastatur hatten alle.
Haben sie noch Mailserver?
Hat anscheinend keiner gekauft, war wohl doof.
Nein, die Hardware-Tastatur war nie ein Argument. Weil es gab ja nichts anderes.
Ich sehe auf einen Blick alle meine eingehenden Nachrichten, Telefone und so weiter. Auf dem Telefon. Als Software-Bestandteil.
Man sieht seine Mails.
Du hast nicht wie bei Apple, mit dieser Mitteilungszentrale, wo alles drin ist, was gerade passiert ist, was du rauslöschen kannst, sondern eher so, all deine E-Mail-Konten sind da drin, SMS sind da drin, Apps, die direkt in den HAP hineinschreiben können, Twitter als Beispiel wäre dann auch da drin. Das fand ich sehr schön. Ja, deswegen ist mein iPhone ja auch nur ein Telefon zum Pokemon Go spielen und Kamera. Und das Kamera.
Blackberry ist doch so eine stinklangweilige Schlips-Company, ohne Vision.
Dieses Telefon ist... Vielleicht sollte ich mir einen Schlips kaufen.
Ab heute nur noch in Schlips, Lety.
Ab heute nur noch in Schlips. Ich brauch noch so einen Bassbird-Bingo-Katalog, damit ich so ein bisschen damit auch noch auftrumpfen kann.
Ja, kein Problem.
Aber du wolltest doch über iOS abbrennen. Ich würde dir ja gerne mithelfen.
Ja, das ist mir aufgefallen, jetzt eben so im Zuge des Wechsels. Was ist mit dieser verdammten Musik-App passiert, dass man...
Also du vergleichst jetzt aber nicht mit iOS 9, sondern so grundsätzlich.
Grundsätzlich.
Bei iOS 9 aber noch, da sah die Musik-App eigentlich ganz okay aus, die Farben ein bisschen an die Alben. Ich weiß, ich hatte mir das in der Sendung schon. Aber das muss man einfach noch mal sagen. Sie sieht einfach scheiße aus.
Ja, nicht nur, dass sie scheiße aussieht. Ich möchte bitte nicht, dass meine Alben, wenn sie durchgehört sind, aufhören. Und ich möchte standardmäßig diesen Scheiß-Repeat-All-Button sehen. Aber den gibt's schon, ne?
Ich hatte ja immer genervt, weil ich komm da ab und zu drauf. Und dann weiß ich nicht, und man konnte ja mit diesem Shuffle noch nie erkennen, ist es nun an oder aus.
Das hat mir auch jemand berichtet. Das ist mir an mir halt vorbeigegangen. Die neuner Version hab ich ja nie gesehen. Und ich weiß nur, ich glaube vorher war das auch relativ nah beieinander, dass du nicht aus Versehen drauf kommen konntest, sondern eher bei der Musikauswahl hattest, dass du den Shuffle drücken konntest und gleichzeitig aber auswählen konntest. Es soll alles immer wiederholen. Ich hab's irgendwie gegoogelt.
Aber wenn der jetzt weg ist, finde ich das gut. Ich weiß auch, wie die das bei Apple machen. Und zwar, die sammeln ja die Daten hier. Und von jeder Aktion sammeln die ja auch die Daten. Die wissen genau, wie du auf den Hauptbutton drückst. Und die wissen auch genau, wie oft irgendwie Repeat oder Shuffle gedrückt wird. Und wahrscheinlich haben sie festgestellt, das nutzt kein Schwein. Und haben es mal in die hintere Ecke geschoben.
Witzig, ich nutze ständig den Shuffle. Ich bin einfach komisch.
Und die Apple, die schwimmen halt mit der Welle. Oder wollen, dass alle mit ihrer Welle schwimmen, wie auch immer man das dreht. Nee, aber die iOS 9, da sah das mit der Musik irgendwie, wenn die Band ein blaues Album hatte, dann war die Seite, wo dieses Album und die Songs waren, die war dann halt auch so blau angehaucht. Das war alles so ein bisschen, dass jedes Album auch so ein bisschen individuell und gut aussah. Weil es farblich immer gepasst hat vom Font, dass sie dann eigentlich schon...
Nee, es hat nicht immer, nicht immer gut gepasst.
Ja, aber das hätten sie noch irgendwie fixen können. Ich fand das war schon ziemlich gut. Und vor allem hoher Wiedererkennungswert. Du konntest an der Farbe schon gleich auf Kilometer Entfernung sehen, alles klar, das ist jetzt das Album. Das war einfach schick. Was ist, jetzt haben sie es rausgemacht. Das ist einfach weg. Jetzt ist hier alles so stinkend weiß. Und komisch. Und auf der anderen Seite, also wie soll man sagen, die Musik war eigentlich immer relativ dunkel gestaltet in iOS 9. Jetzt ist es irgendwie wieder weiß und hell. Und auf der anderen Seite haben sie aber jetzt die Uhr. Also hier, wie heißt das, Clock oder was? Ja genau, die Clock. Da haben sie alles von weiß nach schwarz gewechselt.
Ja, das finde ich auch komisch.
Wollen sie alles weiß machen oder wollen sie alles schwarz machen? Das eine wechseln sie in die eine Richtung, das andere wieder in die andere Richtung. Das passt vom Stil irgendwie überhaupt gar nicht zusammen.
Also was ich bei dir, was ich zum Thema Musik, ich weiß nicht, habt ihr letztes Mal über den Musik-Act am Ende von dieser Keynote gesprochen?
Ich weiß nicht, ob wir darüber gesprochen haben, ich glaube nicht.
Weil irgendwie, ihr kanntet die auch alle nicht, ne? Ich hab mir ja dann mal den Spaß gemacht und hab dann mal in der Musik-App einfach mal so die aktuellen Charts gehört. Da ist ja dieses Lied, was die am Anfang gemacht hat, auch drin. Und wenn du das dann mal im Vergleich hörst, ist das gar nicht schlecht zu der ganzen Scheiße, die da sonst so drin ist. Also macht dir mal den Spaß und hör dir mal in der Musik-App die aktuellen Charts an.
Ich hör mir nie Charts an.
Das ist unglaublich.
Ja, wie gesagt, wir sind einfach zu alt für sowas. Das ist alles.
Na ja gut, ich mein, Sport ist ja nun sehr relativ. Was der eine mag? Was, so Modern Talking oder was?
Nee, Modern Talking war eine andere Art von Scheiße. Also, ja, nee, so viel so, halt so dicke Hose-Rapper und dann so...
Also wie immer.
Passt doch total zu Apple mit ihren Beats-Kopfhörern.
Und dann so ein bisschen Schmachzeug und dann halt so total tot produzierter Pop. Also, wo du dann halt irgendwie eine Hookline hast und die spielen sie drei Minuten lang. Und Text kommt irgendwie auch nicht dazwischen und lautet so ein Zeug. Also es ist irgendwie ganz, ganz merkwürdig. Also nicht, dass jetzt das, was diese Sia da macht, so besonders spannend wäre. Also gerade der eine Song, den sie am Anfang, der klingt so, als hätten sie irgendwie von drei Liedern irgendwie den Refrain zusammen gebastelt und dann noch ein bisschen AOAO dazwischen gemacht. Also es ist irgendwie...
Vielleicht gibt es auch sowas wie den Paper-Generator für wissenschaftliche Paper auch für Musik, also für schlechte Popmusik.
Ja, es hat ja schon KLF schön demonstriert, wie man irgendwie erfolgreiche Popmusik so aus der Retorte durchstarten kann. Da haben sie extra ein Buch drüber geschrieben. Das war doch mit Ankündigungen seiner Zeit, was wir so angekündigt haben, wir machen jetzt hier mal einen Top One-Hit und dann haben sie es gemacht und dann fand es auch statt.
Ja, und dann haben sie irgendwie eine Mille verbrannt.
Dann haben sie die Kohle dann verbrannt, genau.
Verbrannt so richtig, im Sinne von ins Feuer geworfen. Eine Mille Pfund in Papier einfach mal verhalten.
The Copyright Liberation Front. Das sind richtige Discordia im Sinne von richtige, echte Discordia. Also das volle Programm. Nicht Leute, die irgendwie so ein bisschen so discordisch sind, sondern wenn du halt mal so in die Texte reinhörst, dann ist sozusagen alles voll mit Illuminaten-Anspielungen und The Full Monty.
Und die leben jetzt von ihrer Million, die sie nicht verbrannt haben schön irgendwo.
The Ancients of Momo und so weiter. Also es ist sozusagen alles komplett drin verwurstelt in ihrem Programm. Ja, KLF ist grandios.
Also es gab da irgendwann mal eine großartige Doku zu, wo sie halt dieses mit dem Verbrennen von dem Geld... Irgendwie so. Und ich fand das so geil, wie sie am nächsten Morgen, die dann auch gefilmt haben und so eine komplette Carter-Stimmung herrschte, wo ihnen dann so aufgegangen ist, Scheiße, wir haben jetzt wirklich eine Mille Pfund einfach verbrannt und die sind jetzt weg. Das war so, fand ich irgendwie lustig.
Nee, sie sind wirklich total krass. Ich meine, das sind halt richtige, richtige, aufrichtige Künstler. Das geht kaum noch, kaum noch konsequenter. Und das muss man sich echt mal, sollte man sich wirklich mal anschauen, wenn man das irgendwie noch nicht gesehen hat. Und KLF ist einfach grandios. Es war ja auch grandioser Pop, den sie gemacht haben. Aber halt auch wirklich so mit Ansagen. Wie hieß dieses Buch, was sie irgendwie gemacht haben? Da macht er extra so ein Buch rausgebracht, wie man so ein Number One-Hit macht. Da krieg ich da jetzt was durcheinander. Ja, genau. The Manual. How to have a Number One the easy way. Genau. Dann haben sie einfach beschrieben, wie man mit einer Handvoll Samples einen Number One-Hit konstruiert. Damit haben sie sozusagen das ganze System quasi gezeigt. Ja, ist fantastisch. Super geile Discord, Top Notch, Number One.
Gerne wieder.
Also krasse Typen.
So, war das schon alles so eine iOS-Beschwerde? Nee, ich hab ja Lotti gar nicht ausreden lassen.
Ich auch, Dennis.
Das wär anders.
Nee, das ist mir in der Tat aufgefallen, aber irgendwas war noch an der UI, dass ich mir so langsam gedacht hab, wieso müsst ihr immer alles versuchen, jetzt noch anders zu machen.
Du hattest letztes Mal behauptet, dass sie den Systemfond geändert haben.
Bisschen dicker.
Da bin ich irgendwie...
Nein, die haben nicht den Fond geändert, sie haben das Gewicht des Fonds etwas dicker.
Naja, das ist ja geändert, aber...
Na, das wär spellbar. Doch, die Uhrzeit, doch, doch.
Ja, an einigen Stellen, aber den eigentlichen Systemfond nicht.
Na, der Fond ist der selber, aber du kannst den ja extrem filigran in seiner Dicke skalieren lassen.
Ja, okay, die Uhr ist dicker. Und außerdem haben sie in dieser Music App diese Überschriften so fett gemacht.
Sie gehen auf fetter. Also, sie hatten am Anfang so eine totale Filigralität.
Besonders in der Music App.
Und es konnte ihnen einfach nicht dünn genug sein, weil es halt einfach so unfassbar schick aussieht. Und mussten ja schon das Accessibility-Feature, fetter Text und so weiter hinzufügen. Und in gewisser Hinsicht, ich meine, am Anfang ist es immer erst mal so, oh Gott, ist es schon wieder anders, jetzt hab ich mich so gerade dran gewöhnt. Ich muss sagen, das war schon die richtige Antwort.
Also sie haben ja von 8 auf 9 den System von selber geändert, von Helvetica irgendwas, neue glaube ich, auf diesen neuen San Francisco. Aber ich glaube, den haben sie dann jetzt nicht noch mal im allgemeinen Gewicht geändert. Der ist glaube ich so geblieben erst mal.
Ja, der wird ja, du hast auch bestimmt diesen Typografie-Vortrag zu San Francisco gesehen, den sie auf der WWDC gezeigt haben.
Nee, ich bin dann doch kein Typografienerd.
Na das kann ich dir aber mal sehr empfehlen. Also das war wirklich einer der aufschlussreichsten...
Zur letzten WWDC?
Als sie San Francisco vorgestellt haben. Also jetzt nicht dieses Jahr, sondern...
Dann muss es wohl...
Vorletztes Jahr.
Ja, muss dann wahrscheinlich 2015 gewesen sein. Da war ja 9 schon drin.
Ich hab mich so mal wieder eingefallen, welches UI-Element ich noch ziemlich komisch finde und irgendwie immer daneben klicke. Der Snooze-Button bei der Alarmfunktion ist wunderschön groß, trifft man immer, aber den Ausbutton für den Wecker nicht.
Das ist natürlich Absicht.
Ey, boah, das geht mir so auf die Ketten morgens. Ich bin heute schon wieder fast ausgerastet.
Lass mich raten, das macht dich wach.
Naja, ich hab mindestens zwei Wecker, damit ich auch wirklich aufstehe.
Ja, das ist doch genau richtig für dich.
Da kannst du mir nicht außersindlich ausstehen.
Nee, wenn ich da drauf drücke, dann soll das beim ersten Mal funktionieren.
Du musst halt zielen.
Also der Link ist in den Show Notes. Da hab ich gerade den Chat geworfen, Introducing the new system for us. Und da erklären sie halt mal, was das Besondere an diesem San-Francisco-Font ist. Der ist halt jetzt nicht nur yet another font, sondern der ist halt als System-Font auf eine Art und Weise skalierbar und modifizierbar. Also du hast halt alle möglichen Optionen, erstmal so was die eigentliche Dicke betrifft. Und das Ding passt sich dann halt auch dynamisch an und geht dann eben auch sofort in so ein Headline-Format über. Also Headline-Fonts sind ja anders geschnitten als kleine Fonts. Also der mutiert sozusagen auch noch mit der Größe. Du sagst nicht nur, ich will dich jetzt größer haben und dann hast du dasselbe in 48 Punkten, was du vorher in 9 Punkten hast. Sondern der ist dann halt anders. Also der passt sich sozusagen der erforderlichen Optik an der Stelle an. Du kannst halt alle möglichen Sachen konfigurieren. Du kannst sagen, ich will jetzt Nullen, die als Null erkennbar und vom O unterscheidbar sind, haben. Also kriegst du dann sozusagen andere Zahlen oder möchtest du die 9, sodass der Strich unten wirklich rumgeht und nicht nur so schräg gerade runter geht. Es gab noch so diverse andere Kleinigkeiten. Also immer so auch diese Grenzen, wovon es manchmal in bestimmten Lagen anfangen, unpraktisch zu sein, weil sie eben genau in deiner speziellen Anwendung an der Stelle versagen, obwohl sie für viele andere dann eben gut funktionieren. Und das ist etwas, was sie bei diesem San-Francisco-Font halt gnadenlos durchgezogen haben. Du kannst halt auch stufenlos quasi die Dicke einstellen. Das ist ja genau dieses Feature, was so in iOS eben so drin ist. Das haben sie zwar mit Helvetica im Prinzip auch.
Ja, da haben sie schon angefangen mit.
Da haben sie schon mit angefangen, aber bei San Francisco ist das sozusagen Teil des, also der ganze Font ist um dieses konfigurierbare Wesen herum gebaut worden. Das fände ich schon ziemlich cool.
Nee, es ist nur so, wir hatten mit unserer App ja das Problem, dass der Designer gesagt hat, wir nehmen den Systemfont fertig. So, was macht Apple bei iOS 9? Macht einen neuen Systemfont. Und sprich, die App sieht komplett anders aus. Also jetzt fontmäßig unter iOS 8 wie unter iOS 9, was dazu geführt hat, dass wir sämtliche UI-Tests halt neu machen mussten, beziehungsweise die immer unter iOS 8 und unter iOS 9 laufen lassen mussten, weil die Laufweiten von den Fonts natürlich anders sind. Du musst dann immer gucken, passt der Scheiß noch rein, ist das Layout inordentlich und wie macht man UI-Tests? Üblicherweise, du machst halt Screenshots. Und wenn die Screenshots sich ändern, ist der Test rot. Das ist furchtbar, aber es geht nicht anders. Und das Ganze sieht jetzt aber so aus, als müssten wir das unter iOS 10 nicht machen, weil sich der Font als solcher erstmal nicht geändert hat.
Gab es nicht letztens bei dem Gruber irgendwie so ein Artikel auf irgendwie so eine, ja ich glaube auch eine Konferenz, so glaube ich sogar Apple, Microsoft und Google, ne und Adobe, genau, Apple, Microsoft und Adobe so ein neues Font-Format vorgestellt haben, wo genau das geht, was du gerade beschrieben hast. Also dass der Font-Designer nicht mehr sagt, das ist italic und das ist bold, sondern er gibt den ganzen Font ab und man kann halt an so Parametern drehen und dann wird er halt zu bold, aber es gibt also stufenlos sozusagen und der Designer sagt nur noch hier, das ist das bold, so wie ich mir das vorstelle, aber es ist halt nur noch eine Stufe und nicht jetzt speziell halt in bold abgeliefert, sondern das kannst du auch später dann dir noch weniger bold, mehr bold, mehr italic und so, also sozusagen du kriegst den kompletten dynamischen Font mit allen Features, die man so braucht, um das schön zu vergrößern, zu verkleinern und schräg zu stellen und so weiter. Ja, Vektor-Fonts haben wir jetzt ja auch schon, oder? Aber da sind dann wahrscheinlich die Beschreibungen auch drin, wie das halt mit dem bold, also wie das halt wachsen oder kleiner werden soll.
Ja, genau, was ich meine ist, dass du wirklich auch irgendwie einen Engel angeben könntest, für Atellic zu schieben.
Das war bei dem groben...
Open Type Variations in Open Type Version 1.8 ist halt Open Type. Also wir fangen jetzt nicht nochmal an, ein komplett neues Font-Framework zu machen deswegen, sondern Open Type in Version 1.8 kann auch sogenannte Font Variations und da sind dann eben so eine Sachen mit drin. Also es ist so diese ganze Multiple Master Fonts Geschichte, die war so die Vorlage bei Type 1 Fonts und das hat dann irgendwie alles zu Open Type geführt und Open Type Font Variations ist dann glaube ich dieses Feature, was du meinst.
Kann sein.
Das gibt es jetzt seit 14. September diesen Jahres, also mit anderen Worten seit zwei Wochen. Ja, müssen ja mitkommen, aber da ist dann der Abfilmer wieder zwei Jahre vorher schon lang geschlittert in diese Straße.
Nö, schon seit einer halben Stunde, glaube ich, nicht mehr eigentlich.
Na, wir müssen uns jetzt auch nicht zwingen. Nächstes Mal gibt es bestimmt neue Macbooks.
Toll, wenn ich nicht da bin.
Ich dachte, irgendjemand im Chat behauptete... 24.10.
Ah, gibt es einen Termin?
Würden die vorgestellt, ich weiß nicht, ob der schon offiziell ist, aber der wird wohl rumort.
Rumort bitte, das heißt, nächstes Mal gibt es immer noch keine Macbooks?
Wenn wir nicht einmal ausfallen lassen, nein.
Okay, aber wir wären am 26. dran. Dann können sie am 24. gerne einen neuen Macbook vorstellen. Dann müssen wir uns für die nächste Sendung noch was einfallen lassen.
Kriegen wir hin.
Brauchen wir neue Hobbies.
Am 26.
Hast du eigentlich mal dieses Jet Black jetzt in der Hand gehabt?
Nee. Ich hör nur Leute drüber reden. Ich war kurz im Apple Store und hatte überhaupt mal ein iPhone 7 in der Hand. Und es war...
Nicht Jet Black.
Nee, es war einfach nur so dieses Schwarz. Nein, ist das das normale. Sehe ich das richtig, dass hier niemand auf iPhone 7 wechseln will?
Nein, ich hab jetzt ein 6S von der Firma spendiert bekommen. Wenn ich jetzt ein 7 wollte, müsste ich es mir selber kaufen. Das ist mir dann doch nicht wert. Genauso wenig...
Du solltest es erst mal kaufen.
Mir das was wert ist, jetzt eine neue Apple Watch zu holen. Also irgendwie... Wasserdicht genug ist die alte, zum Duschen reicht's. Was ich extrem praktisch finde, weil morgens bin ich, was so Zeit anbelangt, immer so ein bisschen neben der Spur. Und gerade duschen, das tue ich dann doch auch gerne mal länger.
Du legst dir erst die Uhr an. Also egal wie dizzy du bist, du kriegst auf jeden Fall erst mal die Uhr an.
Genau. Und dann geh ich unter die Durche.
Und dann musst du duschen.
Genau, dann kann ich unter der Dusche immer auf die Uhr gucken, wie spät sie ist.
Kannst du mal die ersten Nachrichten lesen sozusagen.
Nee, das nicht, weil der Trick an der Uhr ist... Also ich weiß ja nicht, wie sie es bei Serious 2 gemacht haben, aber bei Serious 1, also Serious Zero, oder wie auch immer man sie nennen will. Da ist es so, wenn du mit der duschst, dann lösen die Tropfen auf der Uhr Touch-Events aus. Das heißt, wenn du das tatsächlich vorhast, mit der Uhr zu duschen, dann nimmst du sie kurz ab, sodass sie lockt. Oder machst du das Armband locker, sodass die Uhr lockt, und dann kannst du damit duschen, weil dann passiert nichts, wenn Touch-Events ausgelöst werden. Bevor ich morgens dusche, lege ich erst mal die Uhr an, so sieht es aus.
Auf jeden Fall habe ich das iPhone 7 kurz ausprobiert, zweimal mittlerweile, und muss feststellen, dass es ein, zwei Features gibt, was mir sehr zu sagt, extrem zu sagt.
Man kann auch damit duschen.
Der Button.
Warum?
So muss das sein. Also dieser mechanische Button war schon immer ein Problem, weil er ist einfach zu laut.
Zu laut, ja. Da habt ihr letztes Mal auch darüber geredet. Ich dachte, was?
Ja, der ist zu laut.
Ich kann das schon verstehen. Also zu laut. Also ich weiß nicht, ob ich das zu lauten... Ja, vielleicht, wenn das so ein Kackgeräusch ist. Weil es gibt ja so einen schönen dumpfen... Weiß nicht, kann man halt nicht nachmachen. Aber wenn es einfach so ein tiefer Ton ist, den man auch nicht laut hört. Aber es gibt auch so ein lautes Knacken, so ein hochtoniges Klick und das nervt.
Ich will nicht in zu viele Details gehen, aber es gibt schon Momente, wo ich sehr schätze, dass es wirklich sehr leise ist, ich aber trotzdem ein gewisses Klickbedürfnis habe. Ich muss halt eine App wechseln. Das ist für mich wichtig. Als Nerd weiß ich, dass es für mich wichtig ist. Und ich weiß auch, dass Non-Nerds das in dem Moment unter Umständen nicht verstehen. Wenn ich einfach die Chance habe, diesen Vorgang durchzuführen, also mein Telefon zu benutzen, ohne dass es ein akustisches Signal sendet, das es jetzt gerade benutzt wird, sagen wir mal, es gibt keine optische Verbindung, nur eine akustische Verbindung. Innerhalb eines Raumes, der sehr leise ist. Du möchtest dein Telefon benutzen, aber es ist dir wichtig, dass nicht unbedingt jeder mitbekommt, dass du dein Telefon benutzt. Solche Situationen, und du kannst dir jetzt irgendwelche blumigen Bilder in deinem Hirn ausmalen, was für eine Situation das sein könnte.
Na, wie man schläft nebenan halt.
Ich gehe da jetzt nicht so ins Detail. Tatsache ist, das neue Telefon kannst du halt einfach klicken und du spürst es halt. Es ist nicht an derselben Stelle, das merkt man schon so, aber ist eigentlich auch total egal. Du kriegst die Rückmeldung, das ist das, was du brauchst. Und es klickt halt nicht blöd rum. Ansonsten brauch ich das jetzt erstmal nicht, weil ich hab definitiv ein Problem mit dem fehlenden Head-Control.
Ist das eigentlich bei iOS 10 neu, dass ich hier ganz doll klicken kann und zieh das so rüber? Ich geh links in die Mitte des Bildschirms, klick da ganz doll und zieh es einfach zur Seite.
Nein, das war bei 7 oder 9. Bei 9 war das schon. Bei 9 war das schon.
Das ist mir letztens aus Versehen passiert, hab ich noch nicht gewusst. Jetzt haben wir so Sachen, die hat man irgendwie verpasst.
Ja, seit es Force-Touch gibt.
Es funktioniert mit meiner Hülle nicht.
Du hast keinen Force-Touch. Das ist übrigens das, worüber man ordentlich ranten könnte. Als Linkshänder hat man ja das Telefon gerne in der linken Hand. Und dann funktionieren einfach verschiedene Gesten nicht richtig. Weil du...
Optimiert sind für die Hand rechts.
Genau, weil der Daumen bei der rechten Hand von rechts kommt.
Bei der Map zum Beispiel jetzt?
Nee, am schlimmsten ist es eigentlich bei normalen Table-Views, sprich bei Mehl. Wo du Mails mit so einem Swipe löschen willst.
Und der geht jetzt in die falsche Richtung, ja, verstehe.
Und du kannst es...
Aber gibt es nicht eine Einstellung für Links- oder Rechtshänder?
Ähm, nee, gibt es nicht. Es gibt in Accessibility jeden Scheiß, aber Rechtshänder gibt es halt nicht.
Dann schreib mal eine Mail! Also...
Das Ding ist, du kannst ja hier dieses Gelesen oder Archive, oder was auch immer du da einstellst, kannst du ja von links nach rechts swipen. Als Linkshänder swipest du aber tendenziell gerne vom Rand. Und wenn du aber links vom Rand swipest, dann gehst du halt zurück in die Navigations-Theorie. Das nervt mich tierisch. Da muss ich mal einen Bug schreiben irgendwann.
Schick ein Bild davon, dass du halt deinen rechten Arm nicht mehr hast, um das Problem gleich deutlich zu machen. Sonst verstehen die das ja nicht.
Ich hab den noch nie gehabt, ich bin Linkshänder.
Aber da sind sie doch immer sehr hinterher mit ihren Support für Links und Rechtshänder und Schrift von Links und Schrift von Rechts. Also das mögen sie doch, dass alles möglich ist, alles kann einfach. Und ich denke, das ist auch so eine Sache, haben sie einfach noch nicht auf dem Schirm gehabt.
Wahrscheinlich, ja.
Ich glaube, das machen die gleich und sofort.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob es so einfach zu lösen ist, das ist das Problem, aber... Nee, aber du musst halt, weißt du, mit dem rechten Daumen musst du halt einmal ganz rüber.
Du machst halt so und du willst das halt von der anderen Seite machen, das ist schon klar.
Genau, mit dem rechten Daumen musst du einmal ganz rüber, um das auszulösen. Aber mit dem linken, da bist du eh immer an der Stelle. Es ist irgendwie, naja, aber genug, da hab ich mein Point across bekommen. The end is nigh.
Genau, the end is nigh, weil wir wollen uns jetzt hier nicht von einem iOS 10-Detail zum nächsten hangeln. Oder? Was sagt Chewbacca dazu? Das dachte ich mir schon.
Vielleicht zu dem Thema noch. Ich krieg's jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht raus. Aber da gab's so ein schönes Video von jemanden, der eine Cola-Dose über den Tisch schiebt. Mit so einem Chewbacca-Bild drauf. Und die klingt auch noch wie Chewbacca.
Die Cola-Dose. Beim Schieben.
Das stimmt tatsächlich.
Hast du auch noch unseren Flash eigentlich?
unseren Flash?
Ja, haben wir schon so lange nicht mehr gehört.
Flash gibt's halt auch nicht mehr.
Ja, doch, Spiegel hat's ja drauf. Spiegel hat sich ja neu designed. Und die sind ja der Meinung, Flash müsste man ja doch irgendwie noch benutzen müssen. Was?
Da hat jemand die Cola-Dose gepostet.
Okay, dann spielen wir die Cola-Dose auch nochmal ab. Was Spiegel online hat.
Manche Videos da ist immer noch, dann kommt irgendwie, ja hier mach mal...
Dieser Spiegel-TV-Kram, der ist halt wahrscheinlich immer noch eul.
Ja, alles ist da eul. Vor allem hier mit diesem Spiegel Plus, wo das dann alles da in Krypto auf dem Bildschirm erscheint, hab ich schon erzählt, dass das eigentlich Rot-Minus-1 ist. So geil. Ich klicke immer oben auf den Reader-Mode, sodass man dann alles sehen kann, mach dann den ganzen Krypto-Zeugs, was man nicht lesen kann, in Buffer, google nach Rot13 online, paste das da rein, sag Rot25, weil das ist ja Minus-1 und schon geht das. Außer dass das Z halt nicht geht, weil das halt, also die rotieren halt nicht nur die Buchstaben, sondern den ganzen ASCII-Bereich, aber da kann man den halt lesen. Aber ja, ich glaub wir fehlen uns jetzt hier nur noch das...
Genau, wir fehlen uns nur noch. Also machen wir jetzt hier mal ein Ende. Ende mit Schrecken sozusagen, ne, Ende ohne Schrecken. Die Herren, die Dame. Wir verabschieden uns jetzt heute mal ein bisschen vorzeitig. Nächstes Mal gibt es wieder eine frische Sendung, da haben wir auch Themen. Ihr könnt uns zumindest auch Themen zuschicken, ihr könnt uns auch gerne was im Slack droppen und ihr könnt es auf Twitter schicken, ihr könnt euch alle möglichen Sachen einfallen lassen, aber heute nicht mehr.
Thank you for coming and we'll see you soon.